Всем привет!
Что с нас так мало?
О, я круто!
Какие у меня обовязковые девчата!
Это супер!
Добре, давайте начнем.
Как всегда, начинаем с нашей рефлексии,
что мне сегодня заважает научиться,
что мне поможет, но все про все 10 минут, поедем в паре.
Всем добрый ранок, Влада, добрый ранок, Настя, где ты делась?
Всем привет, всем привет.
Я как-то не видела, прокаталась по всем комнатам.
Настя, да, погуляла, у нее была небольшая прогулянка по всем комнатам,
она такая, как пошла, так и пошла, и не повернулась.
Видите, какая женщина.
Тут была, тут нет.
Добре, всех приветствую.
У нас сегодня очень классный семинар.
Но перед тем, как мы его начнем, хочу вас предупредить.
Он такой очень глубинный, такого еще у вас не было.
Потому что мы сегодня будем говорить о заборах,
которые давали родители и дают родители в нашем жизни.
Он может этот семинар поднять очень много чувств.
Пожалуйста, обращайтесь за собой.
Потому что мы будем говорить про сценарии, про то, что сказали родители.
Если у вас есть психотерапевты, кучи, менторы,
если что-то поднимется, пожалуйста, вынесите это к ним на встречу.
Если что-то накрыло тут и сейчас, дайте мне про это знать, хорошо?
Потому что семинар действительно очень глубокий,
но я имею четкое осознание, что каждая людина должна понимать
свои заброны, свои, ну, как я говорю, проклятия, да,
которые для нас, ну, так, если образно можно сказать,
пришли от родителей.
Поэтому заранее, ну, я вас передала, это важно.
Если накрывает, скажите мне, потому что может накрыть.
Хорошо?
Хорошо, давайте не тратить время, начинаем, как всегда,
так, на прошлом тоже было много, да, очень много всего поднимается,
Поэтому смотрите, я же научаю вас, вы же у меня взрослые, я же имею надежду, что каждая людина, если ей плохо, она пойдет к психотерапевту и скажет,
«Аларм, у меня есть потреба поговорить с тобой это все».
Потому что, когда мы учимся, знаете, как бы мы про это ни говорили, все равно каждый знает что-то, получает свой инсайт,
и иногда эти инсайты невероятно болезненные.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, обращайтесь к себе.
Добре, я поручу с вами. Почали. Сегодня у нас семинар. Сейчас буду показывать, как он называется. Так.
Смотрите. Мини-сценарии и личный стиль. То есть все как-то ок, все как-то нормально, но это, слушайте, это только прелюдия.
В детстве человек делает решения, которые помогают ей выживать и часто продолжает жить согласно им, не осознавая их похода.
Сгодны? Такая была интересная фраза Эрика Берна, или не сгодны? Как заходит, не заходит?
Если сказать очень просто, кто-то вам что-то сказал, вы приняли свои решения и дальше с этим живете, не осознавая.
Вспомните тот случай, о котором было описано в книгах Эрика Берна, матушка, которая прокляла своих сыновей, сказала, что нехай вы останетесь в психиатрической лекарстве. Один был лекарем, другой был пациентом.
То есть такая, к сожалению, иногда бывает детская доля, что мы не имеем достаточно ресурсов для того, чтобы осознать, что что-то наши родители говорят не то.
Иногда мы можем принять очень болезненные для нас решения.
Поэтому, что мы сегодня будем с вами изучать?
Мы сегодня поговорим с вами про такие основные понятия, как забороны,
родственные забороны, которые нам дают родители или дали в детстве.
Мы с вами перейдем и посмотрим на 12 классических заборон за гулдингами.
Это такие очень классные авторы, они их исследовали, проводили такие марафоны,
Тусы у них были, если сказать отвертко, они забирали людей в себя на 2 недели на месяц и у них была очень классная идея делать перерешение.
То есть они исследовали заброны от родителей, а потом перерешивали, что-то делали по-другому.
Вот, дальше мы с вами поговорим про драйверы.
То есть такая эксклюзивная защитная поведенка, которая включается в момент дистресса.
И, наконец, мы с вами поговорим о мини-сценарии, то есть как эти обороны, эти драйверы, может для вас это сейчас еще необычные слова, но на конец семинара все будете знать, как они соединяются в единую систему и что вы вообще себе там нафантазировали в вашем жизни, то есть вы узнаете много информации про себя, понимаете, какой у вас даже есть сценарий.
И я надеюсь, что как только вы это все осознаете, вы это будете менять.
Потому что я еще раз повторю, когда человек осознает, в чем есть проблема, это уже 50% решения этой проблемы.
Хорошо? Хорошо. Потому что человек уже не может вести себя так, как ведет до этого.
Интересно вам? Хотите таки узнать, что я вам тут нафантазировала в этом семинаре хорошем?
Хорошо, я очень рада, что вам это интересно. Спасибо за ваши реакции, для меня это очень важно.
Давайте, как всегда, мы начнем с контракта.
Я научу вас, как найти какие-то эти особые, эксклюзивные паттерны поведения, которые возникают снова и снова.
Через контракт это сделаем.
Смотрите, контракт очень простой у нас.
Вспомните, пожалуйста, в стрессе, что вы делаете снова и снова.
Например, кто-то становится таким прекрасным.
Очень прекрасная людина, которая начинает все делать идеально.
Кто-то становится сильным.
Кто-то, возможно, в стрессе начинает поспешать.
Кто-то дает радость.
Кто-то очень что-то пытается достигнуть или что-то сделать.
Выбирайте то, что вам отгукается.
Ой, не люблю, когда люди стресс гадают за мной.
Но такая у меня профессия.
Смотрите, вспомните, с чего все начинается.
Потому что каждый стресс и дальше какая-то поведение,
она начинается с какого-то триггера.
Вспомните историю, которая была связана с каким-то стрессом.
Ну, прошлого недели или прошлого месяца.
И есть ли что-то подобное с этими повторенными историями?
Как у меня сегодня был клиент, он говорит, слушай, так, у меня жена триггерит, так, триггерит.
Каждый день что-то повторяется, то же самое.
Ну, то и я вам скажу.
Згадайте, пожалуйста, кто есть триггером.
Далее.
Ну, это уже для меня история.
Подумайте про то, чем вы хотите,
чего вы хотите научиться на этом семинаре.
И как всегда,
потому что мы взрослые люди,
мы знаем, что мы будем себя обижать.
Занутуйте себя,
как я буду себя обижать,
и другим исследовать себя.
Как я себя поддерживаю, вернусь назад к взрослому, чтобы быть в контакте и с собой, и с другими.
Все мои любимые вопросы, я так его люблю, как всегда.
Знаете, я хочу, чтобы это у вас осталось на всю жизнь.
Как я себя порадую?
Мои любимые студенты.
Это, может быть, главное.
Надо давать радость каждого дня, особенно, когда что-то делаешь в выходные.
Гений мой, занотовали? Да? Ну все, давайте, мои розуночки, на 10 минут в паре, чтобы швиденько это все проговорили, выгрузили контейнер и пришли дома надалее учиться. Давайте, даже 8 минут, Юль, потому что мы уже такие, мы уже продвинутые. Добре? 8 минут.
Да, кто у нас слушающий?
чтобы никто меня не слушал, то они в меня так же бунтуют уже несколько курсов, да.
Я шуткаю с вами, да, я понимаю, я ж не могу вас заставить, если можете, присоединяйтесь.
Доброе. Идем, начинаем дальше.
Сегодня мы будем исследовать сценарии, или, как иногда говорят, контрсценарии.
То есть иногда нам родители что-то говорят, и это формует наш сценарий за Клодом Штайнером.
и он сказал, что это как покерная согласие с тем, что говорит нам культура,
то, что нам говорят окружающие, как социальные какие-то требования,
и это все передается нам через родителей.
Знаете, как я говорю, как мы должны себя поводить в местах загального значения.
То есть это все формует постепенно культуральный наш сценарий.
Но про что мы начнем говорить, действительно, что есть интересное.
Например, есть понятие мини-сценария.
То есть, что такое мини-сценарий?
Мини-сценарий – это когда я думаю, что я окей или не окей, если я что-то делаю.
То есть, это формует мини-сценарий.
Мою особливую поведенку.
И я
сгадываю, подсведомо,
что, в чём я окей,
когда я работала в семье, и в чём я не окей.
То есть, для того, чтобы
сгадать свои заброны,
или подумать, какой у меня будет сценарий,
нужно проанализировать
историю, что вам
сказали ваши родители.
Эй, детка моя родная, делай то.
Или не делай то.
Эти голоса иногда
вас преследует чини шоу кому шо батьки казалось что можно и рубит и что не можно и рубит и
так супер шуши не перебивать старших он и прям замечательно дает александр эмоции
не проявляться эмоции бачите в каждой у людей нашествие в каждого из нас еще
Но еще что-то социальное и культуральное, как я говорю, знаю и слышу от клиентов или вообще от людей, говорят женщины и мужчины из Восточной Европы,
очень сильные и не всегда показывают чувства, понимаете? То есть у нас еще есть какие-то культуральные сценарии, которые уже видят другие нации и как они о нас говорят.
Добре. То, коли детинка маленькая, она, начебто, заряжает для себя такую батареечку.
Это называется за Кайлером окей-неокей батарейка.
Да, то есть вся поведенка людская, она начинается с маленького профессора.
Помните, когда-то мы с вами изучали семинары, там, где у нас есть детский гостан, и в детском гостане в возрасте от 3 до 5 лет формуется наш маленький профессор, такой исследователь.
он исследует, он анализирует информацию,
то смотрите, в этот час дитя себе выозначает,
когда она окей и когда она не окей.
И это выозначает ее батарейку,
окей-не окей батарейку,
которая формуется от родителей.
Смотрите, как это все формуется,
как это все выглядит.
Сейчас покажу, у меня есть такая схема интересная.
То есть, когда ваши родители вас выховывали, они вам сказали, что ты или окей, или ты не окей.
Иногда было тяжелое детство, и детина может вырастить с чувством, что она не окей.
А это все было в ней сформовано в детстве.
Смотрите, не окей батарея, это когда родители ставили себя плохо к детям,
и дитя привыкло с детского века подсиливать своего контролирующего родителя.
И если послушать наших клиентов, у них начинается такой критикующий диалог.
Я это плохо делаю, я это плохо делаю, и это мне не очень хорошо.
Какой вывод мы можем сделать?
Что когда эта людина была маленькой, ее родители зарядили ее не окей батарейку.
То есть сказали, что это плохо, это у тебя плохо,
тут ты не отвечаешь моим ожиданиям.
И с самого детства маленькие привыкают, что они не окей.
Поэтому, если посмотреть на людей, иногда люди,
при таком выховании, они дальше становятся взрослыми
и они начинают себя гнобить.
Как я говорю, это очень плохой, критикующий диалог.
Даже если родителей нет, как мне вчера сказала одна клиентка,
мамы нет, но я сама все повторю, все, что она мне сказала.
То есть этот паттерн от малыша до родственного состояния, он всегда идет.
Человек сам себя критикует.
И это есть понимание того, что в детстве ее критиковали.
И тогда человек вырастает с не окей пауэрбанком.
Ну, такой сломанный.
Это понятно?
Сломанный, да?
То есть, человек сама себя подзаряжает на негатив.
Ну, вы же видели таких людей?
Сами, может быть, такими также были.
Да, когда какая-то кризисная ситуация, вмыкается это на окей батарейка, а вместо того, чтобы себе сказать, боже, так было тяжело, так было, ну, очень тяжело, тяжелый час начинается, а почему я не сделала так, а почему я не сделала вот так, а чтобы я могла сделать, чтобы еще раз это пережила по-другому, или пережил по-другому, а что люди скажут, ну и далее вот этот диалог, да, все понятно.
сразу про наше выхование.
Но если нам повезло,
и у нас были классные
родители, а на мой взгляд
таких родителей я еще, чтобы
хорошо посмотреть, не видела в своем
жизни, ну так бывает иногда, да,
родители, может, и хорошие, но не всегда
давали то, что нам нужно.
И вот, уявляем идеальных
родителей, которые были добрыми,
классными, поддерживали
нас всю жизнь, сказали
все, что нам нужно. И
вырастает тогда человек,
Заряджена с окей батарейкой, потому что в ней, в ее детском восприятии, она имела надежную, безопасную, окейную поддержку.
То есть, родители могли конфронтироваться, но были безопасными, поддерживающими, и человек научился заряжать саму свою окейную батарейку, хорошую батарейку, не сломанную.
Как можно посмотреть и найти это в жизни? Например, какая-то кризисная ситуация, а человек сам с собой разговаривает, говорит, ничего страшного, я уже несколько раз с этим впоралась, все у меня было хорошо, до этого впоралась и сейчас впораюсь.
Ну, может, с часом, может, с веком. Мы больше развиваем, когда мы идем в коучинг, в психотерапию, мы уже начинаем сами развивать эту ОК-батарейку, да, мы понимаем, что не нужно верить родственным посыланиям, что нужно себя поддерживать.
И если мы уже такой, знаете, апгрейд сделали себе, достигли этого левелапа, да, наивысшего, то мы можем себе сами подзаряжать эту ОК батарейку.
То есть в сложных случаях поддерживать себя.
Это понятно, я говорю?
То есть каждый из нас имеет эту ОК или не ОК батарейку и с ней живет все свое жизнь.
Иноди це можна змінити, як я вже сказала, але з шляхом психотерапии, коучингу, проработки себе.
Тобто, якщо людина мала не окей батарейку, то чим більше людина залишается в стане не окей,
тим більше її батареечка заряджається.
Чем больше человек стоит или находится в состоянии «ОК», тем больше заряжается «ОК» на батарейку.
И каждую батарейку нужно зарядить до определенного уровня, чтобы она начала работать.
Ну, это же понятно, да? Мы же не можем включить там в пауэрбанк шнурок, чтобы у нас телефон зарядился, если он разрядженный.
Когда наша батарейка совсем разрядлена, мы умираем.
Для людей неважно, какой заряд, окей или не окей.
Для нас очень важно зарядить эту батарейку, чтобы в детстве мы могли оставить своих родителей рядом.
То есть я существую в своей семье, и я окей только при каких-то условиях.
Это понятно?
Да?
Хорошо.
Есть какие-то вопросы в этом?
Нет?
Вспомните, кто как выховывался, кто как себя поддерживает.
Занотуйте себя.
Я себя поддерживаю, а когда мне плохо, я себя заряжаю,
или заряжаю на окей, или не окей.
Это для себя так больше, для рефлексии.
Вот, и дитина выживает, если поддерживает заряд хотя бы с одной батарейки, да, это я уже в такую полярность пошла, сейчас, сейчас, Наталья, если, например, я говорю только окей, или только не окей, но все это есть жизнь, у нас есть что-то окей, то, что есть, и мы получили от родителей, да, то есть есть какой-то позитивный заряд, но не все же мы такие отбитые, да,
есть что-то хорошее, что мы можем вспомнить, а есть и не окей.
То есть, если мы смотрим на обычную людину, есть большинство какого-то заряда.
Або не окей, або окей.
Но подзаряжается с двух сторон в родине, если есть доступ к нормальным здоровым отношениям,
или если есть там не очень здоровые отношения.
Это понятно, то есть подзарядка может идти с двух сторон.
Но одна какая-то сторона, она может быть больше, чистейш за все.
Или более здоровой, или более не окейной.
Наталья, я слушаю вас.
Я рассматривала по себе и по своим клиентам, что действительно так и есть.
Но у меня есть одна клиентка, которая говорит, что ее в детстве мама все время говорила, что она красавица,
папы практически не было, но у нее уровень самокритики и нападения на себя просто высокий.
Требует задать вопрос, кто себя критиковал, кто тебя научил критиковать себя самостоятельно.
Иногда в нашей семье, в наших семьях не всегда мы слышим нарратив ты плохой, ты плохой, ты плохой, ты плохой.
Иногда мне клиенты говорят, на меня мама так смотрела, что я хотела провалиться под землю.
Я думала, боже, это какая мама. И они еще так выхваляются, говорят, моя мама меня никогда не била.
Но смотрелась, а папа на меня как смотрелся. Папа не бил, нет, не бил. Просто его дома не было. А когда был, то он смотрелся так, чтобы писяться можно было.
Ну, это честно, да, это то, что слышишь, действительно, в консультациях, и действительно так бывает, на жаль, это жизнь, да, иногда наши родители, они, ну, как-то смотрят, что-то говорят, или не говорят.
Это также подзаряд неокейной батарейки, да, если у вас, например, на кровать, что с вами люди не разговаривают в момент конфликта, это также было подзарядом вашей батарейки, это понятно?
Но человек хочет эту батарейку подзаряжать, потому что это дает им возможность выживать дальше.
Вот, с батарейкой мы разобрались. Далее. Мы переходим, у нас сегодня очень большой интенсив.
Нет. А ну давайте паузу сделаем.
Давайте паузу сделаем. На 6 минут разбились в пару, выгрузили часть этого материала.
где я окей, не окей, або у меня что-то миксовано.
Что хотите, то и говорите один одному.
Трошки выгрузите, пожалуйста, свой протокол,
что там у вас не собралось,
чтобы далее могли нормально
научиться.
6 минуточек, не больше.
То есть не нужно
какую-то историю про себя там
рассказать, да, но просто скажите,
ну, у меня иногда так бывает,
в момент дистресса, что я себя
могу критиковать.
Або пришла психотерапию, коучинг, критикую себя меньше.
Вот так, легенько.
Добрый день, Юрий Слухач. Я вас разделила.
Как вы?
Есть инсайты, озарения, что-то важное, все нормально, все хорошо?
Понятно, да?
Хорошо, молодцы.
Ой, привет, какая у нас Ульяна тут маленькая, еще одна ученица.
привет красуня привет на лен слушаю я вот сейчас разговаривала с девочками и я поняла что сейчас
мою батарейку которая на плюс подзаряжает очень сильно мои дети они все дома молодой молодец у
тебя получится они настолько подзаряжать что мне вообще совершенно все равно что там в мире и как
оно происходит и то есть ну вообще крутицки те что давали мне установки родители там детство
такое все вот сейчас как бы перевернулась и я получаю обратку от своих детей так что это круто
на самом деле это правда круто хорошо что мы еще можем это принять и взять для себя да потому что
это не факт что кто-то может нам говорить что-то хорошее иногда люди говорят нет нет мне это не
заходят. Окей, секундочку, секундочку. Заходите, быстро. Здесь у меня процесс посетителя Даймонд
пришел. Доброе, а сейчас переходим к заборонам. Да, то, что нам сказали родители, как эти забороны
вообще и формуются. Сейчас мы будем с вами изучать, что такое забороны. Забороны это неизвестные
послания, которые возникают именно из детского эго-стана наших родителей. То есть наши родители в своей
детстве нам что-то говорят, знаете, что-то нам рассказывают, что-то нам показывают и мы это для себя берем. И это
Это возникает под моментом дистресса или когда есть какие-то чувства.
И чаще всего наши родители передают нам патологические установки,
которые есть и могут быть основой для разрушительных сценариев.
То есть наши родители нам что-то передавали.
Как я говорю, свои какие-то заклятия, переклятия и такие не очень приятные вещи.
И мы будем их сейчас с вами изучать.
Сейчас покажу, что вообще Клодштайнер сказал,
Боже, как я обожаю этого дедуся, царство ему небесное.
Все он сказал, что заброны, это эмоциональные проклятия,
глубоко вкоренные и часто неизвестны.
Так, поняли, что такое заброны.
Идем дальше.
И вот мы будем с вами изучать забороны за гулдингами, да, то есть, что нам сказали гулдинги, они нам сказали, что эти забороны, Эрик Берн, кстати, также так сказал, что они формуются во время родственного стресса.
И это, чаще всего, негативное послание, которое мы получаем от родителей, как обороняющий наказ.
А вот гулдинги, они разработали 12 основных оборон.
Вот эта чудовая пара, которая влаштовала тусы такие у себя дома,
такие терапевтические марафоны, как они называли.
И они сказали, что забороны возникают через погладживание,
позитивное или негативное.
Это же понятно, когда нас родители определяют нам увагу,
то мы тогда думаем, что мы должны делать и как мы будем это делать.
И есть еще понимание интенсивности заборон.
Вы уже поняли, что в транзакционном анализе всегда есть какая-то интенсивность.
Как игры первого, второго, третьего ступеня, так и сценарии первого, третьего, второго ступеня.
То есть есть интенсивность.
Есть что-то маленькое, немного пронеслось, а есть что-то большее.
То и заброны, они иногда могут за этой интенсивностью быть или очень интенсивными, или немножко такими, как прошло по вашему жизни.
И чаще всего, дитя получает заброны невербально, то есть без слов, без слов, поэтому они так и работают.
То есть не всегда, как сегодня Наталья сказала, мне такого ничего не сказали. Да, не сказали, а не невербально что-то показывали. И вот сейчас переходим к первой обороне, которая называется неиснуй, или, знаете, в русском варианте вообще не трагично звучит, не живи, неиснуй.
До речи скажу, что 50% земли имеет эту заброну.
Неисную.
Такая страшная себе заброна, потому что, как ее можно побачить и подивиться?
Например, небажанная дитина, не тогда родилась, не тогда пришла.
Знаете, родители могут рассказать, как дитина тяжело родилась.
Вот это мама иногда может рассказывать такие страшные истории.
Или попробую. Ну, вы же прочитали, что не буду говорить, потому что там дети у нас есть, Ульяны, да?
То есть не желаемые дети, так иногда бывает. Но это не к нам. У нас есть желаемые дети, все хорошо.
Давайте вернусь еще дальше, да? Что? Мамы рассказывали истории, как это тяжело произошло в ее жизни, этот процесс.
Втрата с братьев или сестер после или до рождения.
Жестокое поведение. Физическое было или эмоциональное было, или еще что-то. Было сексуальное насилие.
Або частые такие вспоминания, что дитина не желанная. Это главное.
Кстати, люди, которые ем, наркотики, алкоголь, пьют,
имеют эту оборону, много работают, это сразу, я вам говорю, да, это туда,
но там есть всегда условия.
Так, Снежана, вижу, что первое подняли руку.
Да, Влада, спасибо, возможно, я послушала, извините, потому что таблетку купила.
Сиблинги, я не...
Брат и сестра, брат и сестра, это в одной семье называется, да,
это вот это, если у меня есть сестра, то она сиблинг, да,
У меня есть. Супер классно.
Ага, хорошо, все хорошо.
Так, Лера, слушаю.
У меня, знаешь, какое вопрос возникло?
А с какой позиции тогда выходят, говорят, родители, которые говорят?
Да, и про аборты, и про небажанность, ну вот больше про это.
Ну типа это же обычно говорится с какой-то позиции, с какой-то целью?
Страждание, то есть их детская позиция, они в детском эго-стане, знаете, как я говорю, они страждали, я страждала, то и ты страждай.
Вот эти страждания, вот это знаете истории, когда послушаешь, сейчас, благодаря Богу, такого уже нет, да, там люди не собираются и не проговариваются, девчата, если бы не в них сложно было, но иногда девчата вот это начинают собираться на днюхах, день рождения ребенка еще и до сих пор, помню, у меня так в разы в этот случай, да, синдром разорванной матери.
Ну, это вообще страшно, да. То есть, дитя рядом, а мама вот это каждый раз, дитя там 15 лет, она как-то, ой, дочка, ты у меня так родилась.
Або, ой, сыночек, ты у меня так очень быстро родился, и столько было ссоры, столько это все, все произошло, а почему так быстро, я не хотела это так делать.
Ну, там свои процессы в каждом. Дала ответ?
Так, добре, идем далее. Не истнуй. Записали. Next. Что у нас тут далее? Не будь собою. Еще такой топик. Девчата или хлопцы. Да, это когда хотели получить ребенка из другого пола.
Это очень сложно. Это главное, с чего все начинается. Например, родилась девушка, а хотели очень хлопчика. Аж очень ждали этого хлопчика. И тогда девушка все жизнь как хлопчик. Такая инициативная, такая взятая, сильная женщина.
за выправдовые
очекования батьків.
И шо?
Тоді, коли я народжувалася,
а у нас узі не було,
і це був такий сюрприз.
Хто в тебе з'явився?
У ньой батьки,
знаєте, як оце невербально,
як побачила, так і показала
далі дитині.
І це може провокувати
такі наслідки.
Тобто я буду
существовать только в том случае, когда я удовлетворяю твои ожидания, то есть там девушка
становится парнем. Далее, двойное имя, да, то есть женский, такой унисекс, и женский, и мужчинский,
также говорят о том, что есть, ну, такая подавленность, да, дитиной быть своим полом.
Або, например, родилась дитина, а ей дают имя какого-то предка, который помер.
Або брата, або сестры, которые померли, прошел в тот час.
То есть, дитина уже не может быть своей, ну, иметь свою долю.
Она уже подсвядомо объединяется, объединяется к этой истории.
Або постоянное сравнение и критика.
А вот Машечка твоя подружка,
або Сашенька твой друг,
он отменник, а ты что?
Ну, то есть это туда, не будь собой.
Очень сложно, потому что все жизнь потом сопротив.
Девчонки, я вижу, в терапии себя потом привчают до женственности,
привчают быть не такими сильными, инициативными.
короче, сломанная доля на некоторое время. Действительно, так оно и есть. Идем дальше, следующая заброшенная.
Не будь дитиной. Еще один кейс интересный. Вообще мне так нравится в голдинге. Все просто, все просто.
Они разработали эти 12 заброшенных. Да, первое, не будь дитиной. Давайте вам покажу сейчас вот так слайдик и немного больше расскажу.
Дитина смущена поводиться, как доросла.
Або доглядает за батьками,
або доглядает за братом или сестрой.
От детей не ожидает эту зрелость.
И, например, батьки,
которые не позволяют детям быть детьми.
О, что ты плачешь?
Что ты плачешь?
Что ты упал? Не плачь.
Давай вставай иди.
Что, на велике хочешь научиться?
то сидит и едет.
А как я поеду? Ну, не знаю,
как-то поедет. Або выкинули
дитину, например, там, скажут,
ты плавать плыть не умеешь.
Ну, ничего страшного, давай,
я тебя выкину на глубину без спасательного
круга.
Если выживешь, то все будет хорошо.
Ну, знаете, вот такие какие-то
маленькие истории,
которые могут сказать,
что дитина
должна быть взрослой. Она только
уже родилась, а она уже взрослая.
знают и я кажу погляд многовековой мудрости юра я слухаю а я так с братом
срубил со словно плавание мы недавно с ним говорили винду сегодня пометай я не
пометаю я загадывал сырую по смешку и от як мне теперь правильно реагировать и я
не знаю бы я побачу шуму реакция шо я я же научил тебя ты же взял и научился
плавать. Это бы твоя мама учила полтора года. А как меня научили? Я не помню, как я научился, правда.
Я думаю, так же, Юра. Не хочу сейчас сказать ничего особенного. Я помню, что я мало не утопился,
когда первый раз шёл плавать. Меня спасла женщина моего христианства, а потом, как научился, я не помню.
Ну, вы видите, этот детский опыт, я почти не втопился, и ты почти не втопился.
Хорошо, что не втопился, Юра, ни вы, ни брат. Но нужно сказать, ну что, знаете, что еще интересно,
родители говорят, и Юра, может быть, также сейчас подтвердил эту гипотезу, люди не помнят, как они это делали.
Если послушать родителей, братьев, сестер, все у нас было, знаете, как я говорю, полная единорогия,
единорогии, и всегда все у нас было
добро. Батьки вообще в них анамнез,
они ничего не помятают.
Они не помятают, как они тебе
что-то... Да, такого не было.
Взагали не было. Если вы послушаете
батьков, ну, започинаешь, да,
слушать, нет, такого не было.
Ты что? Ты что, дурна,
або дурный? Ну, первое, что нужно
сделать, ну, покаяние,
да, сказать, мне очень жаль, я не
хотел, або не хотела, мне действительно
очень сумно. И сейчас
уже много, много из вас, я вижу,
Вы имеете детей.
Если к вам придут ваши дети,
пожалуйста, не будьте плохими
родителями. Дети
запомнили, значит, так было.
Так было. Все.
Вот, вот, понимаете.
Так было. Что бы вы хотели
почувствовать от человека,
если вы знаете, что так было?
Ну, по-первых,
чтобы вам люди сказали, что
мне очень жаль.
Очень жаль.
Так, а если мне не жаль?
Юра, надо сказать, что жаль.
Людина, брат, почти не втопился.
Юра, ну мне жаль.
Нет, там была очень веселая ситуация.
Мама не могла плавать, она лежала на лежаке.
Ему не было весело, Юра.
Ему вообще не было весело.
Не было весело.
Не дай Боже это пережить.
Если меня мой старший брат выкинет куда-то до воды,
мне вообще, Юра, если вернуться до рельефа жизни,
мне не весело.
Добро, что я еще не придушила подушкой такого брата,
потому что это не весело, это сумно.
Может, вам и весело, а ему не было весело.
Нужно как нормальный, взрослый, эмоционально грамотный человек
сказать, что мне жаль.
Я тогда тоже маленький был, мне было лет 10, ему лет 5.
Я понимаю, Юра, я понимаю, что это не из зла.
Я понимаю, что это была такая игра, что так бывает, это жизнь.
Но сейчас же брат, наверное, не в 10 лет это вспоминает, брат же сейчас иногда это вспоминает, еще сколько лет прошло, я не знаю, Юра, сколько вам лет, но я думаю, что он не просто так вспоминает, наверное, что-то запало не туда.
А это он приехал в гости, мы с ним говорили, мы с ним не виделись несколько лет, мне 28, ему 23.
Видите? Видите? Приехал в гости, 23 года, и еще до сих пор вспоминаю. Нет, нет, Юра, что-то, может, сделал не то, не то пальто.
Нужно извиняться. Просто я так, я могу рекомендовать, но вы можете делать, как хотите. Можете дальше там что-то себе...
Я там сказал ему, братанчик, сорян, типа, 10 лет у меня было, ты опять, ты знаешь, сколько у нас было разума, но было весело.
Ему не весело, Юра, не смейтеся, да.
Людина почти захлебнулась, не смейтеся.
То есть, ну, смотрите, как сами желаете, так и будете делать.
Вы же взрослые у меня все.
Добре, Настя.
Очень спасибо за ваши рекомендации.
Пожалуйста, пожалуйста, Настя, что там?
Да, здесь один нюанс, что лучшая защита – это нападение.
Ну, или отговорки, от смеха, но просто, ну, по факту это стыд.
Извиниться очень тяжело.
У меня тоже была такая ситуация уже даже с дочерью.
Когда она мне пришла и сказала, а ты мне тогда сказала, и шо?
Я говорю, я так сказала, она говорит, да, я говорю, честно, я не помню.
Наверное, я это вытеснила.
Ну, наверное, мне было очень стыдно.
Или я растерялась, или, не знаю, я просто, ну, я извинялась, я искренне извинялась.
И все, и эта ситуация теперь не вспоминается.
Но она вот, ну, не сидела, она ж не сидела.
Ну, конечно, сидит.
Ну, а наша лучшая защита – это нападение.
Ну, в смысле, на нас наезжают, что мы были.
Представь, ребенок пришел, а ты мне сказала, и что, и что я слышу?
А я слышу, ты плохая мать.
Ну нормально, ну что, плохая мать, ну такая жизнь, ну плохая мать, не всегда я хорошая мать.
Нет, ну обычная реакция, первая, секундная реакция, это защититься.
Или промолчать, все, игнор, не было такого.
Не было, ну хорошо.
Ну, как говорила, не было такого.
Кейсы реальной жизни рассматриваем, дякую, дякую.
Так, Олена.
Так, я сейчас пытаюсь сформулировать вопрос. Вы сказали такую интересную фразу, что если ребенок помнит, значит оно было. А я слышала другую мысль с точки зрения того, что ты была маленькая и это твое восприятие, что ты восприняла ситуацию именно таким образом.
но не факт, что мама хотела именно это в тебя вложить, грубо говоря, и я тогда как бы да, приняла тот факт, что, ну, возможно, действительно, да, там, я как маленькая, да, там ничего, ну, не все понимающая, и я там приняла, ну, например, на себя что-то, да, а оно было не про меня.
Ну, так это история мамы, ну, такое у меня было самовосприятие в жизни.
И тогда как? То есть, если я, например, приняла про себя, то в моей представлении эта ситуация была, получается.
Оленя, ну она же у меня не появилась, только что я сама с собой жила, была и сама себя как-то самосприняла.
Я же себя приняла в условиях с моими родителями, то есть это есть влияние.
На меня они влияли, как и на вас, они влияли. То, что они так это не принимали, это их личная думка. А я, как дитя, не имея достаточно ресурсов, подолать свой стресс, вот так и приняла тебя, мама, и что мне делать? Я понимаю, что не из зла, но приняла, видишь, что все, все моё жизнь, я себя и продолжу так принимать.
Вот это меня всегда тратит, знаете, эти родственные разговоры, ну пришла ребенок, сказала тебе, слушай, не очень классно ты мама.
Нет, нет, это не родственные разговоры, это мне так однажды другой психолог пытался раскладывать ситуацию, что ты как-то запомнила, а возможно она была не так.
Ну и хорошо. Но мне это болит. И что? И что? Ну мне болит. Ну хорошо. Помогите мне прожить эту боль. Ну я же так приняла.
Ну да.
Ну ты хорошо. Ну так бывает. Ну что? Ну может люди не могут что-то сказать. Ну так. Кто как хочет, тот так и говорит про это все.
Но я думаю, это не бывает в одну сторону. Так, Маш?
Витаю, немного похворела, но хочу сказать, что это мой сын. Я заснула, и он говорит, что я полчаса выживал без еды, полчаса голодовал. Я говорю, Миха, ты же понимаешь, что я тебе кормлю, но дома всегда полно всего. А ты же мне запомнишь столько всего, что ты голодовал. И говорю, придешь потом ко мне? Он говорит, да. Ну, говорю, приходь, я тебя поддерживаю.
Ой-ой-ой, бедная дитинка голодовала.
Но вы слышали, что дома есть всегда еда.
Поехали домой еще. Что мы тут делаем?
Кому нет что есть, поехали домой еще.
Мы сами все найдем в холодильнике. Погнали туда.
Маша, открывай дверь.
Мы еще сами найдем и дитину нагодуем.
Да, мы нормальные люди. Мы все сделаем.
Добре, дальше идем. Девчата, наступная, хлопцы, наступная заброшенная.
Наступная заброшенная. Сейчас посмотрим, что нам наши голденеги сказали.
А, не будет не расти. Да, в целом. Не расти.
Еще другая заброшенная. Ой, извините, что-то я себе сгадала.
Я вам и так ее расскажу. Ну, покажу, чтобы вы видели слайд.
Батьки не готовы к самостоятельности детей.
И ожидание, что дитя будет маленьким навсегда.
Да, то есть, если сказать просто, прочитали слайд,
они не хотят, чтобы детка выросла.
Это может быть последняя детка, например, пятая, четвертая в родине,
или родители, они не хотят.
Для них это развага.
То есть, собирают, забирают у детей на автономию.
И вырешивают за тебя проблемы.
Да, Клир, слушаю.
В любом случае мы смотрим по своим жизненным историям и родинам и так далее.
А как тогда может быть так, что одну дитину выховывают под одними заборонами умовно, а другую под другими?
Я вот четко проследую, где там мои были, возможно, где еще что-то есть, где по отношению к моему брату.
Как оно так случается, что разные эти обороны и подходы?
Это очень классное вопрос. Во-первых, брат и сестра, они разного возраста, чаще всего.
Ну да.
То есть каждый день у нас родители, они разные. Сегодня у нас, я не знаю, хорошо все в семье, а завтра все плохо.
И там, где плохо, там больше прилетает, потому что это невербальные лекарства, невербальные проявления.
Потом, главное, это самое главное, стабильность нервной системы.
То есть, есть двойные у меня, каждый из них по-разному воспринимает любые послания.
В кого-то вот так я вижу, а в другом он может, в него может быть нестабильная нервная система,
там более чувствительный или еще что-то.
И эта дитя для себя возьмет что-то свое.
Залежит от стойкости нервной системы, от стресса. Сегодня, например, одна дитя в большем стрессе, две ее поставили в школу, она больше принимает информацию негативную от родителей, а другая дитя получила пятерку и все хорошо, и для нее эта заборона прилетела повз.
Может быть так, что эти забороны, ну, умовно, взаимоповязаны. Ну, типа, вот, если мы рассмотрим через призму братьев-сестер, буду говорить прямо примерами. У меня, скорее всего, заборона не быть собой.
того что в батьки было их трое и ты по всей у всех короче татовых братей и сестер были девчата и вся
бляха родина чекал их лоб цив не было и в меню цене будь с собой бы вон и чекал их лоб ця а я
Я вижу по брату теперь, типа, не расти. Ну, условно. У меня отца, знаешь, заборонено быть собой. Я помню, там была отдельная история с тем, как я это прошла для себя.
Но как следствие, в брата, я вижу, ему сейчас 26, по отношению к нему еще до сих пор это не растет. Они решают его какие-то вопросы. Может оно быть как следствие модели одного-одного, или взаимозвязок какой-то, или это какие-то раньше выключения?
Так, это может быть. А ну-ка скажите мне, пожалуйста, что у нас тут за экран появился? Девчата, это не я. Кто это делает? Пожалуйста, если возможно, заберите. О, спасибо. Спасибо, потому что я такая. И что я там? Если я выключила запись в YouTube, Юль, нужно включить?
Нет, у нас есть трансляция.
Ага, есть трансляция, это хорошо.
Так, Лер, оно так и должно быть.
То есть, одна дитя может получать запрет не быть собой,
и все жизнь с ней потом бороться.
Другая дитя может получать другую запрет не расти, например.
И все жизнь дальше с ней быть.
То есть, каждая дитя будет получать свой разный набор своих запретов.
Нет, это я понимаю, я имею в виду, что есть иногда какой-то взаимозвязок, потому что рассмотреть этот пример, ну типа вот они, ну для меня, да, типа не будь собой, потому что ждали парня, они его дожидались, и это же такая прям детенка-детенка, которую невероятно все, и до него типа как последовательность это не расти, как типа, знаешь, какое-то продолжение, какой-то ланцюжок.
А, может одна запорона вытекать с другой, может.
Ну, да.
Может. А что не может?
Да, получили свой подарок и дальше
с своим подарком носятся.
А дитина получает, вот, например,
Лера, ну, извините, да, сразу говорю.
А ты получаешь
еще больше подкрепления, там,
не будь с собой.
Потому что вот тут, вот,
дочекали его, да. Ну, что,
хорошо, а мне что с этим делать?
Ну, вот они дочекали. Да,
они лялечку далее свою нянчат.
А в тебе
есть запрещение не быть
дитиной, потому что тебе
нужно, это уже точно есть,
в него есть запрещение
не взрослеть, не расти,
а в тебе однозначно быть,
не будь собой,
она есть, как ты мне сказала.
Да, и еще больше
подсиливаться на
наступный уровень, не будь дитиной,
то что, то так оно и есть, будешь
серьезной женщиной по своему жизни,
Будешь меньше удерживать радости, да, потому что ту лялю нянчат, а тебе нужно как-то выжить.
Эти забороны, они подсиляют наши сценарии. Нам нужно очень сложно с этим дальше выживать.
Но понимание этих заборон, оно дает нам дальше разрешение. Я потом вам расскажу, хорошо?
Так, вытекает одно из одного. Идем дальше.
Вот эта история про детей, которые навсегда остаются при родителях.
Вот это не расти, это туда.
Ой, божечки, куда ж ты пошла, в тебе телефон разрядженный,
как ты поедешь, тебе 41 рик, как ты доедешь сама?
Нет, я тебе не позволяю, нет света, нет света, телефон не зарядила 40 лет.
Как ты, женщина, одна в порядке на остановке, куда ты поедешь до сестры?
В тебе нет света, зарядишь телефон где-то и потом поедешь.
Это реальный кейс, с чего вы смеетесь?
Женщине 40 лет, батька с мамой не благословили ее поехать до сестры.
Вот честно, честная запрещение. Вот так, не взрослай, да, нет автономии.
Потом эта маленькая лялька дальше с этим все вносится.
Добре, идем дальше.
А что, Олен, да, слушаю.
Я, во-первых, хотела понять, что, ну, уже понимаю, что да.
С первой детьми, может быть, это не росты?
и ну потому что у меня у брата детки и вы колись зараз приклад начали рассказывать и я такая
памятаю значит брат у меня рожонатый у него уже есть детина а мама мне говорит у Саши нет зимних
ботинок давай ему купим я говорю самое то есть тоже самое божечки людочки знаете я иногда
Я потом посмотрю, а у нас какой-то нестабильный перекус, как мамы выховывают сыновей, извините, не все, но у них это бывает, да, вот эта спецзалежность, она несчастлива с твоим мужиком, да, ботинки купили или не купили?
Я сказала, что принеси мои деньги, я тебе дам этот самый.
Ну, короче, был момент, что я буду твои деньги откладывать тебе на великую покупку.
А потом выросло, что Саша на моих ботинках, и я поняла, что все мои деньги будут уходить на Сашу.
И сказала, принеси мои деньги, больше ты их не увидишь, я буду откладывать их сама.
Нарезче, подрослышала.
О, також я не взрослая.
Да, если бы все деньги маме отдала, а они их Саше дали на ботинок.
А я не в пиве отдавала.
Ну хорошо, разумная женщина, не отдавай деньги.
Я просто вылезла себе, потому что она экономная, а я патринькой.
Не отдавай деньги, держи деньги при себе.
Потому что Саша будет в классных ботинках еще и купить.
Да, да. Вот так вот разбирала себе не квартиру, а то все Саше бы прислал.
Ага, Саша будет, а женщина у него есть, пусть женщина купит.
Хорошо, сейчас я не буду дальше философствовать на эту тему.
Но следующая запрещение не делай, не делай, сейчас покажу, где она у нас тут, не делай, или не действуй. То есть, ребенка кладут в манежик, или не позволяли что-то делать.
Куда ты лезешь? Что ты делаешь? Не делай, не лезь на горку, не играйся с детьми на площадке, не трогайся вещей, не будь инициативным, не чипай, залишь. Все, не делай, не делай, не делай. Вот такая установка от родителей, не делать.
Как мы это можем увидеть в клиентских кейсах, это когда ты идешь к человеку, а она что-то сидит и ничего не делает. И ждет, пока мама или папа придет и сделает вместо нее. Не делай, потому что заликали, заликали до смерти, как я говорю, родители заликали.
И люди не делают. Она может рассказать этой человеке, как она что-то сделает когда-нибудь в следующем жизни, потому что в этом жизни она не сделает.
То есть, когда в детстве были ограничения, ограничения, манежик, манежик вот этот хороший манежик, который там детка в мою веку клали, да, поклала и ты там себе сиди и не попробуй, и не можешь, и не можешь вылезти отсюда, так, Лен, что?
Мне интересно, если, например, родители начинают делать там «не расти», там всякие эти забороны, то получается, они делают как бы подсознательно, не специально.
Нет, точно не специально.
Им так комфортно, они так делают, но ребенок-то может не воспринимать эту информацию и делать по-своему.
Вот если он сидит в манеже все детство, когда он выходит на свободу, скажем так, ввиду своего возраста, он идет, пускается во все тяжкие.
Хочу посмотреть на тех, которые высидели в манеже, и потом им, ну, если дали пробунтовать в подростковом возрасте, то все окей.
а если они вылезли из своего манежа и опустились во все тяжкие это тоже пойти в противоположность
к сценарию да то есть где в какое тяжкое в отрыв пошли или делать все что им запрещали
они и она сушу запрет на то интересно и дети туда идут хорошо но может же ребенок продержаться в
этой установке там вот одно из в 1 из 12 там 2 из 12 и потом выйти со своим мнением без этой
установки или мне прежде всего нравится ваш оптимизм 1 2 меня заряжает это хорошим настроением
из 12 я боюсь что большинство найдет себе половину но будем сейчас думать что пока 1 2 я думаю что
то ребёнок пробунтует там, где ему надо пробунтовать, но дело не сделает.
Если ему без конца запрещали это делать, не делай, не лазь, не занимайся,
будет фактически страх, страх начинать что-то делать.
То есть каждый, кто имеет этот запрет «не делай»,
Будет испытывать какой-то панический ужас или, как это у нас модно сейчас говорить, прокастинацию перед началом дел.
То есть не сможет организовать себя, не сможет сделать, не сможет открыть, то есть будет прилагать сверхусилия, чтобы сделать.
Нет, ну хорошо, если он сделал.
Но по факту это будет всё через боль, через сопротивление,
через то, что мы, люди, друг другу не говорим.
У нас же как всё выглядит?
Всё у нас на лайте, всё у нас хорошо.
А на самом деле кто-то берёт себя за шкирку,
через ужас, через страх идёт и делает.
А есть люди, которые не имеют эту забронанную малую еду.
Да? И в них все легенько.
Пошел
в Соби и срабы в Туды.
сразумило?
Лен, дала ответ.
Бунт это не значит сделать.
Бунт это значит
бунт. И хорошо, если
этот бунт происходит в подростковом
возрасте. Часто мы
сталкиваемся с бунтом
в 60-80 лет.
Особенно в Европе. Тут
хохолок зеленый. Я не против
зеленых хохолков 80 лет но это просто креативно это неудобно да ну вымывается или тут 159 черепушек
на 150 килограмм веса я не против черепушек и там байкерской куртки я считаю это круто да я считаю
это классно но если это 159 черепушка на лбу или еще где-то но это говорит о том же каком-то своем
непройденном кризисе или ей 80 лет в обед а у неё пачка как у балерины креативная вышла на улицу я
не против но це все сигнализую говорит тільки про те що ця ну цей досвід підлітковий він не
був пройденый мені жаль я отсумую якщо так відбуватся але добре шо люди в 70-80 можуть
будет взорваться в этом жизни и исправить свои сценарии.
Или я дала вам ответ, что Лера говорит?
Я тут немного вспомнила. Вчера была у парикмахера, она мне рассказывает.
У нее есть клиенты, семейная пара.
И то они вместе ходили, он ее привезет, что-то там где-то.
Она, когда завершает, ему стрижку, и все.
А это ему 46, где-то под 50.
Женщина рассказывает, и он потом сам пришел.
Начал ходить в спортзал, ее с собой не берет.
или без женщины приехал на стрижку, а там уже немного залито, не где еще что-то. И она говорит, сидит 5-50 лет и говорит, а вы мне сделаете полосочку, как у Рональда.
Она говорит, не сделаю. Говорит, я пострижу, как обычно, вы свою полосочку делайте, где хотите, чтобы вы не сказали, что вам Наталья то херанула ту полосочку.
Вот, но насколько это действительно про какую-то непрожительность этих моментов подлитковых, очень интересно.
Да, полосочка, она может и классная, но я боюсь, что тут же вековая криза, тут немножко другое, да, тут же там, это не подлитковый бунт, это в него моложавость пришла, это называется экзистенциальный кризис, который в 40 лет приходит, изменяется гормональная система, и человек, он начинает искать, что он еще не прожил.
Но у меня тут тогда, знаешь, вопрос, может быть вот эта криза последователем тогда запрещения в определенном возрасте, ну, например, если в детстве не позволяли там что-то как-то проявляться, а вот это там, где у нас было не действуй, не делай какие-то такие моменты, и это оно, ну, типа нас догоняет, может это так быть?
Ой, девчата, я так, хлопцы, жалкую, что я вам не смогу дать такие интересные материалы, у меня есть на продвинутом курсе, да, теория развития детей, там уже идут эти вековые кризисы, да, когда возникают, вот это, что ты мне сейчас, Лера, говоришь, это про вековую кризис, это про изменение гормонов, это про то, что было когда-то, это то, что людина изменилась, она не прожила часть своего жизни и к ней смерть приходит, да, ну так, уже больше, да,
часть жизни 40 лет прожита, то мы осознанно думаем, а что будет, если я сегодня умру. Люди не хотят
умирать, это нормально. И они думают, если я себе палаусочку, как вот у Рональда, сделаю, то может на меня
какая-то молодушка еще посмотрит, и у меня будет еще одно жизнь. Потому что, когда я с молодушкой, которой 20 лет,
то я уже забываю, что мне 50 лет, и у меня все идет заново. В 50 лет у меня еще одна дитя, еще одна
Коханка, еще что-то. Это больше до вековой кризис.
Но если, например, заборона, она по-другому проявляется.
Если бы в этом случае он пришел и сказал, что мои родители никогда не позволяли мне делать полосочку.
А вот я хочу сейчас ее сделать. Это было бы про заборону.
Слушайте, 30 минут пошли, все поем, на 10 минут на боковице попьем. Давайте в 40 минут вернемся. Всем смешного.
Наступная заброна. Повертаемся и продолжим.
Наступная заброна. Что у нас тут за планом?
За планом. Так, недий не працюется, мы уже с вами дизналися.
Наступная, не досягай.
Ой, девчата и хлопцы, это родственное заздрение, знаете, изнецинение.
Это когда дитя что-то достигнуло, не то, что было у родственников,
Они начинают говорить, это, может быть, важно, это, может быть, имеет значение. Страх перед успехом через предыдущие травмы, которые были у родителей. И ожидание родителей, что лучше, остаться в тени.
То есть, как это еще понять? Например, у нас же все такие сейчас, вот, вы пошли в коучинг, да, я думаю, ваши родители в коучинг не ходили, 100% есть такие у меня ощущения.
И вспомните, пожалуйста, поведение родителей, когда вы им сообщили, что вы пошли в коучинг.
Доброе, когда родители такие говорят, вау, вау, как круто, у тебя новая профессия, это все так интересно.
Но, знаете, это был такой тоже интересный кейс, родители могут сказать, ну что там, как дела?
Вы им про коучинг, да? А секту? Ну да, мы все уже в сектах, мы это уже понимаем, мы уже смирились с этим.
Ну, то есть, когда вы говорите про достижения своим родителям, а ваши родители говорят, а что там доня, а как там моя внучечка, а что сегодня погода какая-то не та, да?
Вы им говорите про свои феерические успехи в жизни, а вам назад что говорят?
Что это не ценно.
И таким способом вы получаете оборону и знаете, что это возможно и было так в жизни,
если это вас как-то травмует.
Да, как ты с мамой говоришь, теперь я коуч, да, да, очень плохо говоришь,
навчилися коучингу.
Тобто,
знецинение будь-яких
ваших досягнений. И это действительно
травмует, потому что ты хочешь
отримать
поддержку от родителей.
А родители что тебе говорят?
Не будь
лучше, чем мы.
И так бывает.
Так, наступная
заброшенная, наступная
заброшенная, действительно, да.
Что у нас есть?
не думай тематично заборона вон а еще в нас за сценария мы девчонка хлопчик поеду и цяда так
культурально окажут хлопчики все вырежут хлопчики все рублять не завжди девчонка мое дома ты заборона
намысление. Не питай, не выслоплю идеи, не мри, не фантазуй. То есть, когда вы были маленькими и шли
к маме и тату, какие свои гениальные идеи сказали, а они вместо того, чтобы сказать, боже, какая офигенная идея,
это просто космос, моя дитя, как ты у меня родился вообще, это просто нонсенс. Они говорят, боже,
что это за философ у нас, что это за профессор, профессорка или профессор, смотрите, какой он вырос.
И начинают также вас не оценивать, да, и очень сложно потом думать.
Или еще родители говорят, ой, сыночек, зачем тебе думать, мама все решила, мама все знает, мама все понимает,
То есть, они оценивают ваши думки.
Поняли?
Або, або, або, смотрите, когда у вас есть клиенты,
вы их спрашиваете, а что ты про это думаешь?
А человек говорит, я не знаю.
Это также может быть запрещено думать.
Записали?
Гений, занотуйте себе, если что-то нашли,
Поставьте хрестик
себе, да, сделайте себе галочку
«Так, нашла, буду
работать».
Ой, потому что потом уже вам
право дам на дозвол, и будете
делать дальше, расколдовать
один одного, да.
Добре, идем дальше, не думай.
Не чувствуй.
Ох, люди,
не чувствуй, такая интересная
запрос, как можно проверить.
Сейчас лайфхак вам покажу
и расскажу.
Ну, по-первых, это
родители говорят,
«Хлопцы не плачут, дитчата не гниваются,
сразу не чувствуй».
Дают эмоционально
такую приглушенность,
говорят, «Будь сильным, что ты впал,
встань, иди,
чего ревешь, не плачь».
Но как можно
узнать, что у человека
есть эта заборона?
Вот сейчас будете удивлены.
Смотрите.
В онлайне так не сделаешь, но если ты подходишь к человеку, а она от тебя отстанавливается, ты к ней, а она от тебя.
Сразу.
Это как раз под тобой. Ты хочешь к ней дотронуться, а она от тебя шарахается.
Иногда это может быть историей эмоциональной травмы.
То есть что-то было то, что порушило границы с детьми и было тяжело.
Так, не чувствуй.
И сильные наши люди, когда ничего не чувствуют, не чувствуют в том, не чувствуют стресса.
Сейчас я думаю, что когда ты посмотришь на украинцев, у них есть тотальная оборонка, не чувствуй.
Еще люди живые, они еще и общаются, они еще и как-то разговаривают один с одним,
но люди не чувствуют, уже привыкли к всему, такой посттравматический шок у нас,
что мы уже не чувствуем, шахер лежит, летит, да, все равно, два летит, все равно,
света нет, все равно, да, то есть такая она иногда может быть под влиянием социума
больше подсилена и больше сформована.
Добре, мои хорошие, идем дальше. Не будь важливой. Не будь важливой – это когда игнорировали вас или игнорировали ваши потребности. Вам сказали не высовывайся, отчепись, не будь важливой. Не было времени, поддержки и внимания к вашим интересам.
Так бывает.
Но, внимание, сейчас расскажу еще один секрет.
Когда вы были маленькими,
у вас был свой стол за столом?
Свой.
Вот только мой, и никто туда не сядет.
Была такая роскошь в родине?
Если этого не было, то эта защита есть.
Дама на сын гоняет, не дай Боже, кто сядет на его стелец, встань, будь ласка, встань, я тебе говорю.
Это мое место, да, то есть, когда ты понимаешь, что за столом в тебе есть твое место.
И это означает, что ты важный.
Слушайте, давайте что-то еще немного доброе поговорим.
Возможно, вы ездили к бабушке, а бабушка или к дедушке, и они были очень хорошими, добрыми людьми к вам.
То может там у вас что-то было? Бабуся
какой-то стильчик там взяла
себе, подушечку какую-то вам нашила,
поклала.
Если было, то
напомните это. Это было, это важно.
Не было, блин. И тут не было.
Ну что это такое? Ну, нужно
напомнить. Знаете, я говорю, всегда на каждую
людину, которая дает заборону,
можно поискать где-то там
в архивах, людину, которая тебе
очень хотела.
Чтобы это не было так трагично,
так тотально. Потому что сейчас мы все
12. Слушай, это только 12
заберут за голдингами.
Потом появилось еще 3, их 15.
А за Макнилом их
вообще 25.
Чтобы мы себя
не убили от того, что мы прочитали
после этого семинара, нужно
угадывать что-то доброе. Кто вам давал
дозволы? Доброе?
Так, не будь важливым.
Занотовали, галочки себе поставили,
в кого там месть не было, в кого еще
что-то поставили. Молодцы.
Идем дальше.
Наступная заброна, очень важная, не належь. Ой, не належь. Слушайте, это дети военных. То есть, когда ты переезжал из любого места, изменил школу, то ты можешь быть чувством этого, знаете, чуженца среди своих.
То есть не только социально, этнично, культурально,
свет через своих, когда ты приехал в село, в город,
или изгои в своей родине.
Вот всех любят, вот там я не знаю, братика любят,
а ты, как будто, тут чужой.
Знаете, как мне клиентка сказала, у меня иногда ощущение,
что я, как будто, в родине, как чужой.
Чужой.
Как пришла, они все там в трех, а я одна.
И есть иногда это как запрещение, как ненависть к своему роду и к своему колу.
Тут, понимаете?
Далее.
Еще немного улучшения.
Запрещение не чувствуй, не будь близким.
Когда ты не можешь себе позволить быть близким с другими людьми.
То есть, недоверие к миру и другим.
И это, что может быть реакцией, также отсутствие телесного контакта.
Как у меня сегодня клиент сказал, слушай, я вспомнила свое прошлое, свое детство.
И мои родители никогда меня не обнимали и не сказали мне, что они меня любят.
То так и сформировались заброны, не будь близким.
Да, то есть, когда не было принято в родине обнимать, целовать,
сказать что-то, что как-то проявлять эти чувства, эту любовь,
Возможно, возможно, возможно, и есть эти забороны. Я тут чат прочитала. Давайте на 12 залишимся.
Нет, а у нас еще будет МакНилл. Я же хочу, чтобы вы у меня разумничками были.
То я вам еще дам трошечки. У него трошки инша конфигурация, и он очень прикольно, до речи, это рассматривал.
12, так. Это основы, которые должен знать, на мой взгляд, каждый.
Так пришел к клиенту, узнал все запрещения, и потом его поддерживаешь.
Но есть там дальше очень интересные запрещения.
Замокнило, вам расскажу про это очень быстро потом.
Хорошо, и наступное, что там у нас, не будь психично здоровым.
Да, или не будь здоровым.
Это либо гиперопека, либо такая ипохондрия,
то есть вторая выгода от болезни, когда ваши родители предъявляли внимание только тогда, когда вы болели.
Вот, например, работают, работают, работают, дитина захворела, они все сидят, бульончик носят, чай носят, обеспечиваются.
То есть дитина себе где-то подсознательно формует, что я могу отрабатывать внимание только тогда, когда я болею.
И что, это трагедия? Это трагедия, потому что человек встает, взрослый, и когда ей плохо, она что начинает делать? Хвореть. Уже родителей нет, она хвореет. И так можно еще отрабатывать оборону не быть психически здоровым также. Там травмы есть.
Хорошо, давайте немного отрефлексируем, чтобы выпустить этот пар, кто там что в себе нашел.
Пожалуйста, сейчас можно поделиться в паре и сказать, у меня такой инсайт.
Так, на 12 минут. Нет, давайте на 10. 10, чтобы недалеко пошли.
Что, как оно в вашем жизни сложилось?
Ничего страшного тут нет. 10 из 12. Да, это вообще просто победитель.
Ладно, что не все 12. Ладно, что не все 12. Я сейчас всех вылечу. Я сейчас расскажу, что можно с этим делать. Ничего страшного тут нет. Да, просто отрефлексуйте. 10 минут по 5 минут каждой стороны. Поверните.
Как пришли эти забороны? Кто давал, возможно? Рефлексуем.
Добрый день. Я вас делю по парах.
Юля, а можно далее поеднаться будет еще раз в такие самые группы, добро?
Не расформовывайте цель, да?
Не расформовывайте.
Добре.
Инсайты, озрения, как вы?
Так, Лер, слушаю.
Я сейчас подумала про одну еще заборону.
Девчата делились в нашей группе, не на леш.
Но они как-то наводили пример через призму, там, родины и так далее.
может ли эта запрещение, наоборот, транслироваться в разрезе социума?
Навожу пример. Не будь белой вороной. На что, типа, так выделяться? Ну, вот такого плана.
Ну, типа, нужно принадлежать к какому-то более скромному серому пласту и так далее.
Это может быть запрещением, не принадлежащим? Это можно рассматривать как какую-то другую?
она начинается из родины акулы ты не такая как ты бы очеку волы и бачил и да и вонада
елки свои коренья с родины а потом проявляется у социуме так лен слушаю ну не знаю я все-таки
у себя нашла только две вот эти вот новость чудесно может быть я уже конечно свыклась с
этими установками и я живу я не понимаю что эта установка ну как бы так такое может быть скажем
так это хорошо или плохо потому что конечно хорошо ли она у но это же замечательности только 2 мы все
рады мы идем праздновать это событие слава может к массе идем праздновать машина и и полный
холодильник да именно туда идем это чудесно но если ну это установки неживи которую вы
нашли или не нашли лишь бы у вас ее не было моя мама моя мама рассказывала как я родилась я родилась
ягодичная и у меня всю жизнь это вызывает чувство гордости что я не такая как все я даже родилась
по-другому да ну как то вот я не хочу вас конечно сейчас расстраивать но обычно когда мама говорят
о том что есть какая-то эксклюзивность это значит не от радости даже если она так рассказывала об
этом не но она не с радостью она это рассказывала просто говорила как факт то что вот так было все
да так было но это я не хочу рассказывать это внутриутробный сценарий сценарий ребенок
повернулся ягодицами то есть это риск нерождения даже не знаю что сказать но я родилась и слава
богу я говорю что это самое лучшее что могло произойти это правда реально самое лучшее да
потому что это угроза жизни и смерти вообще в рождении ребенка это реальной жизни да мы все
должны ее учитывать слава богу что родилась ли все мы рады идем праздновать второй раз к маша
хорошо нас слушая у меня 10 из 12 и это прекрасно это чудесная новость мир и у кем я стала а стала
я х классным 40-летним мужиком достигатором добившись всего в жизни сама смогла монетизировать
я правильно поняла все все минусы перевела в плюс в течение всей жизни и живи и живи но что у меня
пастила inside смотрите основа слова не расти то есть я была взрослая самого маленького детска и
меня не коснулась не будь здоровым но мне вообще было не выходно болеть потому что у меня все хрен
забивали там кидали таблетки или хочешь лечись заботы особо там какой-то не было все работали
всем было никогда а вот но я бунтарь ребенок было я вот сейчас провела такую параллель что я стощим
ну то есть то с чем я столкнулась я не хотела дать это детям эту установку дальше вот эти 10
я старалась не давать но старшую расти растила именно не расти куда ты торопишься надо кайфануть
от детства ну которого у меня не было и вот не расти и вот что пожалуй до плоды такие что 24
года и мы только год занимаемся полной такой сепарации таким взрослетьем и старой расти теперь
расти расти расти мой цветок хорошо лучше раньше чем позже да да и вот это вот не будь здорово у
меня не было и то есть я гипер то есть когда она заболевала гипер я поняла что она вот один период
ну очень ребенок болезненькая была старшая и я просто не говорила что давай мы будем прогуливать
официально школу там как 22 дня в месяц и разрешала прогулять официально школа она
сама выбирала дни и она ну вот это вот все перестало болеть это замечательно я очень
рада хороший лайфхак получается того что я уходила от того что я сама прожила я старалась
им не давать но на эти два которые меня не зацепили я вложила оторвалась да по полной
но правильно правильно вот пожалуйста алгоритм запрета не это не достигает через это да ну
молодец ира слуха я дичь надо быть сегодня свято на кожу забору купляю веточку ставлю
гарный, величезный букет.
Роблю себе привитание, чтобы
выжила, пережила. Идем в
смены. Вот так. Он будет
величезный. Если что, додать этих 12,
25 и там цель. Ну, короче, мы
выберем. Но сколько всего
пройдено. И сегодня,
благодаря, в принципе, выжить.
Сегодня мы тут,
вместе и крутишки.
Крутишки. Все хлопчики,
девочки, вот это.
Дуже крути. Так, ну а что?
Ну, таке життя. Так было. Ну, есть
усведомления, ничего страшного
тут не ма, да, ну, це не соромно,
ну, так життя склалося, ничего,
вырешимо це питання, це добре.
Снежан.
Влада,
я вот думала над забороною
типу не быть здоровою,
але в мене в дитинстве
там никто мною не опікувався,
даже коли я была
нездоровою, ну, типу
давали таблетки и все.
Але я пережила, будучи
уже в дорослом витте, 7 операций.
Три на око, три на ногу и одну на руку.
И я сейчас себе вспоминаю, пока девчата говорили, что у меня есть запрещение, не достигай.
Что все эти операции были тогда, и вот сейчас у меня спина с того на сего тоже начала болеть.
Это всегда происходит тогда, когда у меня начинается злоба.
Когда у меня начинается, например, поглубление в профессии, я иду вперед, у меня начинают быть какие-то достижения.
То есть, ну, я начинаю, когда я начинаю пертый прямо в достижениях, да, и мне кайфово от того.
Меня вот вкладывает, потому что спина сейчас начала вкладывать, а до того меня вкладывали эти операции.
Это скорее забороны не достигай, или это забороны не будь здоровой, или это то и то?
Не достигай и, возможно, также частично не будь здоровой, потому что нет временного исследования, да.
То есть, что делали наши родители? Мы же копируем их систему инудиценности.
Например, у одного родственника ходили по лекарям, а у других родственников вообще никогда не выживешь до лекарей.
Даже сейчас там какая-то кризис.
Что они там знают?
Да, вообще, что туда, как моя мама сказала, что я буду, зачем мне делать, они калечат.
И докалечилось так, как я говорю, посмертно.
То нужно иметь такой анализ, смотреть, что я делаю, как они, или что я делаю по-другому. И, как сегодня Лера сказала, и мы уже исследовали, одна оборона может вытекать с другой.
Спасибо, Снежана. Катя?
Хотела уточнить с приводу первого забронника, про то, что вы говорили про рождение детей. То есть своей детине, если это были проблемные пологи, мы не имеем права, лучше про это не говорить и не озвучивать, даже если будет спрашивать, что типа все пришло хорошо?
Ну, все прошло, ну, главное, дитина ж народилась, это ж правда. Ой, боже, как классно, что ты в меня народился или народилась. На этом фиксировать внимание, да, то есть про процесс не говорим, мы вообще, да, ну, пологи, это ж, ну, за счастье, сейчас нашу медицину, то вообще просто, ну, просто родила, народила, отдохнула.
И нужно так детям и сказать, да, не формировать вот этот страх, что что-то было не так. Но мы можем исследовать, как проходили пологи, мы можем исследовать, как дальше, как прошли пологи, такое будет и жизнь.
Нет, ну, допустим, если там экстренные там роды были, там ребенок чуть не умер, этот ребенок не должен знать об этом.
Ну, если уже сказала, то сказала, да, но по жизни у этого ребёнка, Катя, будет экстренная жизнь, да, то есть он везде будет приходить и экстренно, очень быстро идти дальше, то есть как ребёнок родился, как мы родились, как мы появились, так мы и живём.
Да, Оль.
Да, Влада, я тоже хотела спросить, частично ответ получила. У меня самая важная заборона, это не будет важливая, потому что у меня был младший брат, и я была его как няней, его интересы учитывались, мои нет.
И мне Уляна в кабинете задала вопрос, а забороны не дей и не досягай, твои или нет?
И я вначале сказала нет, а потом задумалась, что всё-таки я действовала и достигала всего того, что было важно моим родителям,
что они хотели видеть в братья и как бы ему это предрекали.
Я этого достигла, а то, что я поистине хотела сама, я даже долго не понимала, чего именно.
Получается, у меня была эта заборона.
Получается, да, потому что мы, Оля, стремимся порадовать наших родителей.
Прежде всего, ребёнок через радость наших родителей, он выживает.
Поэтому мы можем то, что наговорили или мы подхватили, что это ожидалось от кого-то,
идем сами реализовываем а потом такие хоп проснулись как-то в каком-то возрасте думаю
так это же не моё так хорошо чудесно насть у меня туда же вопросы еще возник по поводу рода
вы говорите но не говорить но а у них это не фиксируется они это не запоминают они может
быть и запоминают но акцентировать на этом внимание не надо подсознание тот видишь вот
так идет видно это не знает но все равно да как родился такой идет но знаете просто есть
всегда акцент какой-то такой когда мама драматизирует или когда мама что в фокус
туда и внимание естественно если просто у меня вот молодежь и друзья старшей дочери они все
я слышала у них просто стороны как они там идти по все за по залету ну типа что такое время все
родители женились и женились и сходились когда только происходил процесс на сначала беременность
потом это у моих там старших и бабушек дедушек они сначала женились потом у них дети рождались
вот и вот они и среди молодежи я слышала это такую историю что тебе там все таки это типа
ну получать как нежеланные до своего род тире нежеланные на что им тогда говорила тоже вот так
решили можно сказать и по залету этаж каком я ощущение аффекта было твоего отца или там твой
папа был от меня в восторге что так же замуж не хотела выходить я говорю данную так детям не имеет
никакого отношения дети всегда то желанные у меня были мнения не найдите всегда появляется от большой
любви что мы вкладываем то они дальше транслирует до любую историю можно рассказать по-разному
делайте эти истории интересными для ваших детей а вот драматизм уберите потому что драма и так
будет много в жизни так хорошо лена вижу ли она подняла руку да вот я бы мастер задавая этот
вопрос мне кажется что все равно внутриутробные травмы тоже есть конечно и ребенок когда выходит
вот я например сейчас у мамы не могу там что-то спросить потому что мама уже нет а жизнь чтобы
поменять свою то матрицу какую-то жизни мне может быть было бы необходимо важно а можно у мамы не
спрашивает ли она но и так все видно если есть какие-то патроны которые повторяются чисто
гипотетически мы можем посмотреть да ну там проанализировать это порассуждать и посмотреть
там та информация которая у нас была как ее можно использовать в этом мире как она пересекается или
откликается со мной я поняла да то есть например стремительные роды стремительно влетаю пространство
да там завоевываю часть внимания дальше желанный ребенок ну например там желанного пола до люди
что ожидают увидят то подтверждают этому рады до ожидали увидеть ребенка другого пола стремительно
влетаю но люди почему-то ожидают от меня другой реакции другого поведения и люди испытывают шок
иногда при появлении этого человека то есть вот этот вот родовой процесс он потом повторяется
много раз нашей жизни мы можем его понаблюдать даже если родители не цели просили проанализировали
все равно легче когда ты знаешь этот процесс не но это же не факт знаете что мама нашего возраста
там сяду ты такое тебе откровение но нет ее не сказала так не сказала ничего теперь сожалеть
уже и так сказала самое главное до ягодичное прилежание не очень-то хотелось вам идти в этот
мир скажу вам по-человечески да по простому не думаю что вам там очень нравится да иногда тот
мир который вас окружают уже вспоминая ваша история которая есть и понимаю что и к некоторым
людям хочется повернуться той частью тела которое вы родились ничего удивительного в этом нет и так
все понятно хорошо так хорошо ель слуха у нас лишь тема ну батьки вски забороны а
як на приклад старшее поколение ну на приклад там бабуся казала нашу вам та
друга дитина а я почула в бишь старшему витте цены часто я как история ли один
раз было, но мама наголошовала на том,
а мы очень хотели.
Ну, то есть,
это же тоже все равно влияет, что где-то
в родине, там старшее поколение,
где-то не хотело.
Или как тут? Так, записываем бабулю
в черный список.
Бабулю вычеркиваем,
да, выкресливаем
запрошение до себя
на день рождения.
Бабуля все померла, ну, то есть,
я не чувствовала от нее,
Но, например, от родителей очень чувствовала и постоянно расслаблялась, что все равно это влияет, если в родине, хоть и не родители.
Ну, она не хотела. Значит, в вашем жизни, Юля, будут люди, которые не будут вас хотеть.
Вы будете зайвы. Может быть, это будут какие-то более женские фигуры, которые более взрослые, которых вы будете безумно дратовать.
И будут люди, может, такого века, как вы, да,
которые будут вас принимать адекватно, и вы будете им понравиться.
Ну, это жизнь, девчата и парни, это все повторяется.
Будет какая-то...
Нет, именно вопрос о том, что это все-таки тоже влияет как-то.
Ну, то есть, если это в родине, не обязательно это родственные забороны,
это могло быть...
Влияние. И бабуся, и дедушка называются родственными фигурами.
То есть, если вас отдали дитячок еще и на выхование кому-то, то сразу это не только там тату и маму, которые на вас сплынули, это тату, мама, бабуся и дедушка. То есть, вы взорвали джекпот, потому что вы получили больше, чем могли от всех.
Доброе, если их уже 4, то ты уже не знаешь, как с этим бороться.
Доброе, давайте далее.
Так, с этим мы с вами разобрались.
Вам интересно это все?
Да? Ну, я рада.
Доброе, я рада, что вам интересно, что вам это заходит.
Нет, сидим, мучаемся теперь тут все.
О, Лер, да что это мучается?
Сейчас мы расколдуем.
Не нужно это драматизировать.
У нас есть очень хорошая новость.
Что нам нужно с этим делать? Вы узнали свои ограничения, узнали ограничения своих клиентов. Не драматизируйте. Нам нужно давать разрешение. Терапевтическая работа, нам нужно людям дальше давать разрешение.
Как мы даем этот позволение? От нас, от нашего внутреннего детского состояния, мы будем давать позволение другим людям на каждую оборону свой позволение.
Но есть одна условие. Перед этим вам нужно с вашими клиентами сделать безопасный пространство. Это первое.
Второе, вы должны уже иметь влияние, то есть ваш голос, ваша сила, она должна быть больше за родителей.
Как одна моя клиентка сказала, слушай, я тебе благодарю, благодаря тебе я живу.
Благодаря тебе я живу. Я мало помарта. Я мало помарта. Я уже делала за день до того, как до тебя пришла, суицид.
Но так случилось, что ты появилась в моем жизни, и поступово, благодаря тебе, меня бы тут не было уже много лет.
но я есть. То есть нужно формировать безопасный пространство со своими клиентами, поддерживать и
дальше давать разрешения. Как мы будем давать эти разрешения? Что мы будем делать? Есть одна особенность,
Для того, чтобы вы смогли дать дозвол, вам нужно иметь 3П.
Вот такая штука у психотерапии, у коучинга.
Пишите себе, это очень классная история 3П за Кроссманом.
Что такое 3П?
3П.
Это такие 3 обязательные условия.
Показываю, что такое 3П.
То есть нам нужно дать разрешение нашим клиентам Permission, Protection и Potency.
То есть создать Protection в безопасном среде, где клиенту с вами комфортно, спокойно.
И давать людям потенциал для взросления, такую силу, power, также, да, то есть давать силу, уверенность и компетенцию.
То есть нам нужно быть человеком, который создает безопасное средоточие, дает разрешения и имеет свою собственную силу, за счет которой ваш клиент будет эти разрешения принимать.
Далее. Для тех, кто взорвал джекпот и имеет много заброн, как с этим работать?
Когда у нас есть заброны, не будьте здоровы.
Сейчас занотуйте. Я так вылечила много людей.
Пишите себе, если кто-то рядом с вами болеет, не дайте ему погладить, когда он болеет.
Эта людина больше не будет болеть.
То есть, если у вас, например, есть такая поведенка, ой, киточек, умейте, захворел, на тебе, ось, чай, бульончик, компот, лежу с тобой, целую, обнимай, и человек будет возле вас хвореть.
Но я говорю, сохраняйте эмпатию, так я тебя понимаю. Захворел. Дети тоже очень любят это делать. Сделай так, чтобы болезнь была неинтересной. У меня еще старшая дочь, я все еще вспоминаю, говорит, мама, ты какой-то, ну просто, я не знаю, ты какая-то магия.
Я говорю, донечка, а что я такое сделала, кицунчик? Она говорит, только я захотела прогуляться в школу, подивиться в планшеты. Ты к мне приходишь и говоришь, кица, моя родная, ты же заболела? Да, да, да, мама, я заболела, мне очень плохо.
«Добре, треба хворіте, давай сюди, Сонечко, свій планшетик, треба відпочивати, треба, щоб мозок відпочивав».
І забрала той планшетик, в мене дитина на наступний день, щоб була здорова, пішла собі до школи,
каже «Більше після цього, мама, я з тобою не хворіла».
Тому зробіть, будь ласка, хворобу, ну дійсно, якщо ви там відчувате,
что це вже, знаете, повторилося один раз, повторилося другий раз, повторилося 133 раз,
Вы чувствуете, что в человека формуется заброшенное, не будь здоровым, пожалуйста, сформуйте так, чтобы это было некомфортно.
Видите, у меня есть коллеги, которые делают так же, как и я.
Невкусную еду? Нет, невкусную, нет. Очень невкусно нужно носить еду, когда человек болеет.
Это не вкусно, не нужно. Не нужно поддерживать этот нездоровый патологический симбиоз, как я говорю.
Добре. Значит, забронуя, не будь здоровой.
Уже разобрались? Занотовали себе?
Ну, я думаю, что это важно сейчас, чтобы мы знали, как с этим быть.
Далее.
Наступно, ну, то есть акцент всегда делайте, что людина здорова.
Заброна не думай.
Вам нужно заохочевать ваших клиентов,
высловливать их
думки.
А что ты думаешь?
А как ты думаешь?
И еще,
до речи,
если эта людина
высловливает думки,
в которых
она не согласна с вами,
дайте ей
погладживание.
Дайте человеку погладживание. Скажите, Боже, как интересно ты думаешь, даже если я не согласен с этим.
Но классно, что ты мне не подкоряешься.
Вот классно, что у тебя есть своя думка.
То есть, нужно дать погладживание за самостоятельное думание.
Далее.
Окремая заборона, не чувствуй, не чувствуй, оно расколдовывается тем, что мы очень эмпатично, очень с эмпатией ставимся к другим людям.
То есть, есть такая, понимаете, эмпатичная транзакция.
Я тебя поддерживаю, я очень уважаю твоих чувств, я тебя слышу.
Давайте возможность человеку почувствовать, что она жива через эмпатию.
Что вы сейчас будете в меня делать?
Будете делать очень классную работу.
У вас там были занотованы забороны.
Вам нужно сформировать на каждую заборону свой дозвел.
Например, один участник формирует запрещение, говорит, что у него есть «не чувствую».
Другой отвечает терапевтическим или коучинговым разрешением «тебе позволено чувствовать сумму злости»
или «тебе позволено чувствовать».
То есть на каждую запрещение мы даем разрешение.
И это не означает, что вы сразу, например, в человеке есть запрещение «не живи».
Это не означает, что вы сказали «Боже, я так рада, что ты живой».
Но это действительно будет работать, если вы один раз скажете, я рада, что ты живой, я рада, что ты есть.
Например, у меня клиент, у него есть обороненный живой, много лет я его знаю, я ему говорю, пожалуйста, я тебя прошу, не разрушай себя, для меня очень важно, чтобы ты остался живым.
Пожалуйста, я понимаю, тебе нравится ездить на мотоцикле, это офигенно, это очень круто, но пожалуйста, купи себе защитное оборудование, очень классно, что ты живой.
Скажи, а как скорость? Нормально ездишь? Не 200 км? Молодец, ты знаешь, что максимум 120 км по автобану. Я не твоя мама, но, пожалуйста, очень классно, что ты живой.
И вот так, как наротив, мы весь час повторяем. Давайте поединяемся дальше. В нас Юлю я попросила, чтобы остались те самые пары, которые были.
И мы на 10 минуточек снова подаем себе дозволы.
Отпрацюем. 10 минуточек в тех самых парах, чтобы не вытрачать время, которое у тебя.
Как жизнь? Студенты? Все хорошо? Нормально?
Я не шикарная, Влада. Вообще.
Да? Нормально.
Так, хорошо. Все живы, здоровы. Все нормально. Все в взрослом.
Вам рассказать о замокнилах? Очень интересно.
Еще немного про эти забороны.
Такой был дедушка, на мой взгляд, просто шикарный.
Он взял, поделил эти обороны, еще и больше их подсилил.
Но я вам расскажу, как с этим работать относительно него.
Потому что, на мой взгляд, он больше эффективно в этом работает.
Хотите это узнать или нет?
Конечно, да. Что за вопрос?
А, да, что за вопрос.
Ну, вы знаете, да, если там будут немножко русскому разговаривать,
я же привыкла, знаете, эти все обороны выкладывать русскому,
то давайте, будете мне помогать.
Давайте, пойдем далее.
Значит, вот этот дед МакНилл, сейчас я его найду.
Что он вообще придумал?
Где наш? Вот он, МакНилл.
Он придумал понятие, вот это такой чудовый дед,
забронные сообщения.
То есть в него он сказал, что есть от родителей забронные сообщения.
Сейчас я вам немного про это расскажу.
Про то, что он вообще придумал и как с этим всем работать нужно. То есть, он сказал, не скажите забор, скажите забороненные сообщения. И он выозначал это как сообщения, которые выходят от родителей, неизвестно, с негативным смыслом, передаются в контексте, как забор, и противоречат природным жизненным потребностям.
То есть жить, привязаться, иметь свою идентичность, компетентность и безопасность. Что он сказал? Он сказал, что заброны намного больше, чем было. То есть туда и до заброн еще есть такие. Не насолоджуйся. То есть не насолоджуйся жизнью, не насолоджуйся тем, что в тебе есть, не насолоджуйся вообще ни чем. Не будь успешным. Также он туда добавил.
Далее, не будь благодарным, не будь вдячным, то есть не будь вдячной человеком, не скажи, что тебе сделали хорошо, не расслабляйся, заброна, то есть человек весь час на прузе, то есть он добавил, не будь сексуальным, это также одна из заброн, которая появилась позже, которую исследовали,
И она имела очень большой влияние на жизнь пар и не быть счастливой человеком.
Вот то, что он туда подавал.
И он сказал, что эти все послания, эти все забороны родственные, их можно объединять в пять групп.
Пять групп.
Первая группа – это выживание.
Это что? Выживание.
Другая группа – это привязанность
Третья группа – это идентичность
Компетентность и безопасность
Теперь очень классная речь.
Как он выяснил эти забронные послания?
Он сказал, что это правдоподобная лжи,
которую мы когда-то слышали в нашем детстве и поверили в это.
Вы понимаете, какой ресурс офигенный, да?
Людина говорит, что это правдоподобная лжи.
То есть эти послания были правдоподобной лжи.
Нам лжи, люди. Нам лжи.
И он сказал, что эти забронные послания не исчезают полностью
и могут проявляться в любом критическом моменте.
Дитя было решением отчаяния, когда ей сказали такую правдоподобную ложь.
И она решение отчаяния за Макнилом, это когда человек говорит, что я очень сильно боюсь, что то, что мне сказали, будет действительно правдой.
То есть, человек, детка, она упала в веще, и было страшно, и она думала, боже, я так боюсь, что это будет правдой.
Далее, в каждой детине было решение неповиновения.
Оно, думаю, в жизни мне перекладывает.
Я не знаю, как это сказать. Решение неповиновения.
О, классно, классно, Юра.
Решение не подкоррения, то есть это дитя искало лучший способ,
как справиться с ситуацией и остаться здоровым в этой семье и иметь хоть немного силы.
Далее, что она делала?
Еще есть до этого замокнило.
Копинговая поведенка, то есть она копировала эту поведенку от своих родителей.
как ребенку нужно поводить, чтобы выжить в этой семье,
и это уже потом становится патологическим процессом и нас, и наших клиентов.
И как он лечил, потому что это была правдоподобная лечь,
Он ликовал новыми решениями, то есть каждая людина могла сделать и решить это, что делали гулдинги.
Они делали такие марафоны, встречались люди, например, людина первый этап осознавала заборону.
Потом она думала, от кого эта забронная идея, садила эту людину на стол, например, там дата не хотела чего-то, мама не хотела чего-то, и начиналась разговор на двух столах.
То есть, человек представляет себя дитиной и говорит, слушай, возможно, ты хотела дитину другого пола, но в тебя не родился или не родился я. Это твоя личная проблема, а не моя.
То есть через это решение не подкоры, через перерешение люди решили, например, а я буду человеком своего пола, а я буду такой, как я хотела быть, а я буду искать, какой мне нужно быть счастливым.
И дальше, что нужно было делать?
Человек делал перерешение, то есть получал разрешение.
А наша задача была, как кучи, как терапевты,
следовать, что человек это интегрирует в жизни.
И вернуть ее снова и снова до здоровых паттернов поведения.
Например, как я вам сегодня сказала, пожалуйста, не ешь 200 километров,
ешь, пожалуйста, 120. Это нормально на автобане.
То есть мы как такой орган, который контролирует,
правильно ли наши клиенты работают.
И он разработал такой довидник посланий,
позволяющих посланий,
которые помогали клиентам.
Например, если человек считал, что его жизнь неценна,
он создал такую, как аффирмацию «Моё життя драгоценна».
Если человек считал, что она втомлена, никто её не любит,
он создал аффирмацию «Есть люди, которые про меня пекаются».
То есть он ставил эти все обороны под сомнение.
И он сделал такие послания, которые помогали людям выживать. Так, Снеженко, слушаю.
Мы можем их, Влада, найти? Потому что я вижу, что у нас в методологии это не есть.
А его вообще не есть? Я вам немного абгрейт сделала, я никому это не говорила, да, потому что это очень расширяет программу.
Но я вам сейчас несколько слов про это скажу, хорошо?
Их где-то можно найти в литературе?
Да, да, можно найти такой довидник, называется «Дозволы за МакНиллом».
МакНилла вы уже видели, пошукайте, есть книжки.
Спасибо, спасибо, Влад.
И давайте сейчас быстренько немного про это поговорим.
Первая категория – выживание.
Туда идут такие забороны. Не истинный.
Только не спешите, я записываю.
Добре, потом еще будет запись.
Не яснуй, не будь здоровым, не доверяй, не торкайся.
И туда еще есть такая оборона, не будь психично здоровым.
Так, так, Снеженко, что там?
А перед психично здоровым что было?
Не будь здоровым, не доверяй.
Не торкайся, что было.
Не торкайся, это уже, да, после психично здорового.
Послушайте просто, как это будет выглядеть.
Это самые рейтинговые паттерны поведения.
Всегда будут люди.
И у людей есть такой состояние «я покажу тебе».
Вот видишь, я тебе покажу, все одно я тебе покажу.
То есть такой прояв, как будто силы и отсутствие почувствований.
Они могут быть неуважными к своему благополучию.
То есть они себя игнорируют в этом.
Они имеют эту гневливую структуру и они все время доказывают своим родителям, что они имеют сенс, чтобы жить в этом мире.
Это правдивая лжи.
Я не имею значения.
Это то, что человек думает о этих 5 заборах.
Подавленное почуття никого не хвилює, що я відчуваю.
Це те, що було з дитиною у дитинстві.
Сцілення.
Потребно дать понимать человеку, что существует, безусловно, любовь.
То есть я тебя люблю просто так.
Далее. Новое решение. Я драгоценный или драгоценна?
И новый голос, за которым нужно следовать.
Ты незаметный. Не руйнуй себя.
То есть, это все нужно анализировать, поддерживать человека,
смотреть, как это происходит, и весь час повторять.
Ты дорогоценный, ты действительно очень имеешь большое значение в этом мире. Иснуй.
И поддерживать в этом человека.
Следующая категория – привязанность.
Туда заходят пять таких заборон.
Это то, что Лера тебе сегодня сказала.
Не будь дитиной и не желай.
Еще одна заброшенная, о которой не говорили гулдинги.
Не желай.
Знаете, есть люди, которые не хотят и другим не дают хотеть.
Такие, как я говорю, гады в нашем жизни.
Ну, они не зла, но очень сложно с такими людьми жить.
Потому что они не могут хотеть самостоятельно, и когда ты проявляешь себя, я хочу это, я хочу это, а они говорят, а почему, а что, а что ты хочешь, а может оно нужно, а сейчас такое жизнь, да, то есть ты весь час с такими людьми под сомнением, и твоя дитя, в основном, она не может порадоваться, потому что есть.
Как это можно посмотреть? Трудности, которые возникают у этих людей.
Очень пригнищенный, ну, не имеет эмоциональной грамотности иногда.
То есть не всегда могут осознать, что с ними происходит.
Иногда они перфекционисты по жизни.
Но у них есть глубокая травма покинутости.
То есть они себя чувствуют покинутыми.
Или они доминируют в отношениях,
тем самым от себя отставают людей.
И вот это желание отчаяния получить любовь от других людей
Заважает человеку самостоятельно даровать эту любовь другим
Потому что такие люди голодные, они хотят только все для себя
А брехня, яку вони прийняли, це «мене не можна любити».
Давнишнє почуття, мене ніхто не любить.
СЦИЛЕНИЕ
Давать любовь, вместо того, чтобы
ожидать ее от других.
Давать тем,
от кого ты чувствуешь, что это, знаете,
поединение душ.
Или такая химия идет от этих людей.
Давайте им любовь.
и просить про любовь, когда она тебе нужна.
Новая истина, которая есть, я могу любить.
И поведение, которое нужно контролировать, то есть смотреть, да, я могу любить других, я могу любить себя.
Далее. Да, да, Настя, слушай.
А с чего тогда лучше начать, например, начать фокусироваться?
Сразу всё? Тоже как бы, да, квест ещё тот.
Ну, например, начать любить себя, потом начать дарить, любить другим, потом уже просить.
Ну, тут как бы сразу всё это такое тяжёлое.
У меня сразу всё, конечно, не получится.
Вот то, что сегодня больше заходит, где меньше сопротивления, то и делаем.
Ага.
Ну, может, есть там какая-то родственная душа, которой ты ещё не говорила,
что она тебе очень откликается возьми и напиши а я родственная душа сама с тобой
до по жизни я поняла хорошо наступной идентичности что-то до входит не будь собою
Не будь автономным, або не истнуй окремо от меня.
Наступный.
Не будь побаченным.
Не будь важливым.
Не вовлекайся.
Как это?
Не залучайся.
Не залучайся эмоционально.
Что тут важно?
«Людина не воспринимает свою собственную личность,
потому что часто была незамеченной, непомеченной в отношениях.
Может иметь свои собственные, очень классные таланты,
но игнорует их и не показывается в мире,
потому что поверила в правдоподобную брехню.
Я ущербный человек. Я ущербная
людина, или как?
Вот такую брехню
поверила.
Никчемна.
Спасибо, Юра. Я никчемна
людина. Вот это верит людина.
И давнешнее чувство,
почуття, это
меня никто не ценует.
Что нужно сделать, чтобы исцелиться?
Нужно заменить желание тем, чем договориться с другим,
с правильным желанием исследовать себя.
То есть, понять, какой я на самом деле есть.
Какая я на самом деле.
И сказать, что я поддерживаю свою уникальность или особенность.
И то, что нужно контролировать, что человек считает себя уникальным и поддерживает эту уникальную красоту.
Т.е. раскрывает свои таланты.
Далее. Компетенция.
Не досягай, не взрастай, не думай, не будь успешным,
И не чувствуешь свободу действовать.
Трудности, которые возникают.
Человек верит в то, что в дальней перспективе
все равно она никогда не достигнет успеха.
Единственное, что ее стесняет, это конкуренция, соперничество только.
Она видит, что у кого-то что-то есть, и она начинает тогда что-то делать.
И чаще всего в ней сопровождается страх неудачи.
Брехня, в яку повирила. Я не вдаха.
Почуцца давнишня, яке отрюмала в родиня. В мене ніхто не вирить.
Что нужно сделать для этих людей?
Учить их получать удовольствие не из-за того, что кто-то говорит о них хорошо, как критерии их успеха.
А нужно их научить получать удовольствие именно из-за процесса того, что они делают.
Новое понимание, мое жизнь, оно интересное, и я получаю удовольствие от процесса.
И следовать за тем, чтобы человек получил удовольствие именно от того, что он делает.
Ну что, вы нормально? Успеете? Все нормально?
Давайте последнюю безопасность закончим и пойдем отдохнуть. Это нормально?
Чтобы мы уже не перерывали.
Вот, молодцы.
Давайте, пишите.
Наступная группа – это про безопасность?
Не насладуйся.
Не будь благодарным.
Не чувствуй.
Не расслабляйся, то есть не чувствуй себя в безопасности.
И не будь счастливым.
Какие трудности?
Людина створит свое жизнь через, знаете, как стает поленепронебийным,
то есть таким, всегда створит себе какие-то сложности.
По життю, как броню себе наращивает.
Когда что-то чувствует, игнорует эти чувства, не говорит о них.
Я знаю, что, если сказать просто, нет чувства жизни.
То есть, человек что-то делает, может делать очень красиво, очень классно, но не имеет в этом жизни.
Потому что когда-то им было очень плохо, и они поверили в то, что они пустые и не уверены.
Те, что им транслювали в родине, тобой никто не цікавится, ты никому не цикавый.
Сцеление – это благодарность.
Еще можно вернуться к прошлому и вспомнить, как уже человек решил эти вопросы раньше, то есть ресурс в себе.
И есть такая штука нормализация.
У этих людей либо все должно быть хорошо, такая радость в жизни, либо все плохо.
Поэтому нужно сказать этим людям, что, например, меланхолия или делирутин,
что происходит каждый раз, это нормальный прояв жизни.
То есть нормализация, стабилизация этих людей.
То, что им нужно поверить, что их жизнь, она станет красивой, интересной.
Им нужно научиться получать удовольствие.
И эти удовольствия будут приносить им уверенность.
Вот так.
Интересно?
Вы молодцы.
Вы даже взяли и Макнила
подивились.
Идем мы сейчас на отдых.
Это нормально, если вы
вернетесь в 30 минут?
Или в 33 минуты?
Что вы хотите?
В 30 будете?
Приходьте.
Потому что я в прошлый раз вас отпустила на больше.
Давайте, в этот раз отпрацовываем.
Добре? 30 минут.
Давайте, я вас жду.
Так, вернемся все и продолжим.
Скажите, у вас есть какие-то вопросы на сейчас?
Что все понятно?
Нет, мои.
чеки испытания лад у меня есть вопрос скажите пожалуйста я нашла абсолютно все у себя это не
сразу да ну вопрос это же может быть разная степень и травматизации правильно я не могу
И может ли быть расщепление, что ты в какие-то моменты, допустим, не чувствуешь,
ну в какие-то определённые ты понимаешь, когда, а в какие-то слишком много чувств.
Да, конечно. И такое может быть.
Всё зависит от степени стресса, как мы уже говорили,
и степень влияния этого запрета на нас.
Какие-то больше, какие-то меньше, но не бывает же всё на 100%, правда?
да и получается степень вот этой травматизации она потихонечку уходят когда мы психотерапевтируем ся
правильно да точно если есть другой человек например у которого или там психотерапевт
психотерапевт работает в отношенческом подходе легче проходить эти запреты или имеет достаточно
силы чтобы помочь справиться со всем этим тоже можно прожить это не ужасно пожалуйста
пожалуйста на здоровье пожалуйста знаете раз разумеется одну речь c нежахлива все
тыщи вы знайшли в своем житии все еще и зараз вас на цех семинарах цены я катастрофа все можно
заменить это главное все так я вижу что вам все понятно все понятно вопросов больше таких
относительно забор он не имеет если что-то есть пожалуйста спросите меня да если нет то мы идем
далее. Мы сейчас с мамой начнем изучать, что такое драйверы. Что такое драйвер? Драйвер это такая
защитная поведенка. Это запропоновал нам изучить Таби Калер. Он разработал эти драйверы. Сейчас я
вам покажу подраздел драйверы. То есть защитная поведенка, которая активируется в механизме
И тогда, когда человек считает себя окей, то есть она как-то каким-то образом поводится, потому что это поддерживает ее окейность.
И есть 5 драйверов. Занотовуйте. Радуй других. Будь сильным. Будь досконалым. Намагайся. И поспешай.
Ну, на мой взгляд, звучит красиво. А вам как?
Я вообще первый раз, когда слышала, думаю, боже, какая красивая история.
Почему вы это говорите, что это что-то не то, что нам нужно?
Красиво назвали, правда? Будь досконалым.
А кто не хочет быть досконалым? Будь сильным.
А кто не хочет быть сильным?
Но у каждого этого драйвера есть свои особенности.
То есть, чем закончится мое жизнь, если я буду таким?
И мы это все сейчас будем исследовать.
Идем дальше.
Как можно понять, что человек находится в этой драйверной поведенке?
Что она делает?
Через слова.
Через жесты.
Через тон.
Через позы.
И через выраз обличья.
То есть мы на поведенковом уровне видим, что с этой людьми что-то происходит.
Это понятно?
Это можно увидеть.
Все легко.
Далее, давайте с вами тогда исследовать, как формуются эти драйверы.
Драйверы, они формуются как ответ на не окей позиции
относительно ребенка, как не окей.
То есть каким мне нужно быть, чтобы меня считали в этой семье окейным.
И как исследовал это Таби Каллер, он сказал,
что драйверы, они сначала
створят такую иллюзию,
что это классная история, что это
добрая поведенка, но
в стрессе это переходит в
патологические шаблоны,
которые поддерживают наш
неокейный сценарий.
Вот так оно
происходит. Тут
понятно?
Не совсем, Влада.
Давайте.
Можно повторить своими словами. Дитя пытается стать ок, для того, чтобы выжить в определенном среде, оно для себя формует поведение, когда оно ок для этого выживания.
И это поглибливает или усиливает ее неокейность.
Не окейный сценарий.
Снежана, подивитесь на ваш
пример. Вы сказали, что мне таблетки
дали и сказали, что идея моя хорошая,
сама себя вылечу.
У меня есть гипотеза, и я думаю, что она
будет далее подсилена
и тестами, что у вас есть драйвер
на поведение быть сильным.
Конечно.
Да, то есть я окей,
если я сама пеклуюсь про себя.
И это было не...
Да, и это было тем, что было обычным у вашей родины. Кроме этого, я гипотетично могу понять, что возможно, как гипотеза, у вас есть еще один додатковый драйвер радовать других. Гипотетично, это не прояв, но он может быть.
Бо якшо ты сама, дитинка рідна, береш собі пигулочки і сама себе ними годуєш, то когось ти цим радуєш.
Тобто я окей, якшо я сильна, то ще даю радість іншим. Сніжано, це моя гіпотеза, це не означає, що вона має бути.
Це правда? А скажіть мені будь ласка, може бути таке, що маючи ось це все, що ви описали,
Я привлекла к себе такую женщину в жизни, своего другого мужа, который пытается своей поведением меня от этого забрать. Мне не нужно его радовать, мне не нужно быть сильной. Может быть такое, что я настолько втомилась от того, что я... Но я не умею это принимать.
Алеш, не принимаете, то драйверная поведенка есть.
Если бы принимала, то бы сказали, что вам другой человек дарован от Бога, чтобы вы немного отдохнули.
Ну, так вот.
Ну, так вот. Добре. Дала ответ, Снежан. Зрозумела зараза?
Я зрозумела.
Добре, добре. Настя, я же вижу все. Настя, говори.
Ну, я вот просто даже про первое радую, сейчас еще раз для себя уточню.
То есть, всегда какие-то моменты. Моя защитная реакция.
Улыбаемся и машем.
Ой, да всё классно.
Ой, на операцию иду, ну, ну, ну, что, а?
Ну, вот это вот всегда, да, или какой-то стресс,
я всегда начинаю всех там вокруг радовать, что не так уж и...
Не, начиная всех утешать, да,
сама просто умирая от страха где-то глубоко,
ну, почему же я буду бояться?
Опять-таки же, Снежана и Настя у нас с хуже психотипом, да, личности,
поэтому ничего удивительного нет, внутри сильное.
Историю про таблетки сами рассказывали,
И что? И радует других.
Да ты не волнуйся, да я решила.
Да, а триггером всей этой истории получается то,
что моя мама была в такой жертвенности,
такая вся несчастная, и я ее всегда веселила.
Конечно.
Потому что, кстати, ты понимаешь,
что если она сейчас в таком состоянии помрет,
то я помру автоматически, как детеныш и я.
Логично, Настя, умничка.
Все верно, все четко и все по сути.
Ничего лишнего.
Вот так вот это и формируется.
И дают нам это все наши родители.
Да, как ты выживешь, если у тебя мама канает от своих депрессивных эпизодов.
Это, кстати, может быть при депрессивных матерях, при жертвенности, при болезнях родителей.
При том, где родители не могут нормально обслужить детей.
Ну да, где ты становишься родителем своих.
Да, да, да, да, да, да.
Дала ответ на все вопросы.
Теперь понятнее становится, что такое драйвер.
О, я рада, я рада, что я смогла объяснить.
Хорошо.
Хорошо. Давайте я вам сейчас буду показывать, как эта штука научно формуется.
Не только я, бла-бла-бла, но есть еще такая штука.
Смотрите. Радуй других.
Батько. Батьковское послание, которое вы получите.
Ты окей, если радуешь меня и других, и я ожидаю, что другие люди будут меня радовать.
То есть, то, что транслюровали родители.
Малюк. Те, которые вас интруицировали, то есть, вы его себе интегрировали.
Я окей, если радуюсь другим, или тебе.
Понятно?
Вот так штука формуется с этими драйверами.
Идем дальше.
Быть досконалым.
Снова берем эту родственную фигуру, которая говорит, что ты окей, если досконалый, и я ожидаю от тебя досконалости.
Но, к сожалению, что происходит в этом мире, досконалости нет, но маленький, маленькая детка думает, что я окей, если я досконалый для других.
Бачите, какие гады
эти батьки и мать были?
И знаете,
и звица, и оцей синдром самозванца.
Что все,
что ты не зробил,
воно не так дискринало.
Ты шо, серьезно?
И оце по всему
житти, шо недостатню гарно...
Да, Настенька, можна додати.
Ну, эта фраза, типа,
да, но могла бы
и лучше.
это жесть это же лучше не могла бы мама покажу но она триггерит всю жизнь когда вера потенциал
могла бы лучше дает и вот это но она когда слышишь а нож прям до сих пор ничего настенька
Пройдет, с годами это проходит, ничего страшного. Я говорю, идите, покажите мне пример. Я же хочу посмотреть, где вы так досконально были, как это у вас проявлялось.
Но, кстати, слушайте, это действительно большая проблема. Потому что родители такие, они задроты. Они не могут, они не ценят почувствия своих детей.
Так, что у нас дальше? Дальше у нас идет драйвер.
потому что страх быть осужденными на самом деле другие еще это вообще особый драйв их
это их профессиональная история позже живут себе или покоится с миром до самое главное что я с
этим буду делать так слухать и далее а далее будет сильно но вы уже разумеешь и дебать киевские
переконания, да, как посылание.
И есть ответ Малюка.
Будь сильным, ты окей, если ты сильный.
И я ожидаю, что ты будешь
сильным. И другие будут сильными.
Что? Соберись, тряпка, как это нам
сказали, да, когда-то иногда.
И Малюк тогда думает, я окей, если я сильный
для других. И я окей, когда я
сильный для всех.
Далее. Намагайся.
Ты окей, если намагаешься.
И я ожидаю, что и другие будут пытаться что-то сделать.
Маленький думает, что он окей, когда он пытается для других что-то сделать.
Далее, вот эти родители, которые никак не могли успокоиться в символе «швидше, швидше, швидше».
Родители фигуры сказали, что ты окей, если ты швидкий, если ты что-то такое, что ты гальмуешь, не тормози.
Будьте быстрее.
Что делать? Это у меня.
Спешу всегда. Что делать?
Дайте, скажу. Я же говорю, что сразу видно драйвер.
Да? Видите? Видите, мои хорошие? Добре, добре.
И я быстрый для других. Добре, что делать? Что мы делаем?
Есть эти ссылки, которые нам нужно проанализировать от родственников.
мы делаем с клиентами им нужно сделать такую упражнение ты окей если да и далее
нехай клиенты запишут окей они если то есть это требования к другим сейчас сами себе
сделайте для других людей ты окей если и напишите пожалуйста все что вы хотите
Это то, что вы, люди, добрые будете давать своим детям
или своим родным.
Ты окей, если.
И далее все свои ожидания.
Что-то там накатайте быстренько.
Так, Настюш?
Отношение к другим людям, ты окей, если?
Да, ты окей, если.
Ты окей.
А я окей, если?
Не-не-не, Настя, вот смотрю, например, на возлюбленного, или смотрю, например, ну, детей не берем, да, это другая ниша немного, берем на других людей и думаем, ты окей, если. Можно взять своих супругов возлюбленных, потому что они сразу, ну, как зеркало, да, они сразу проявляют твои ожидания.
Почему-то мне не вкладывается это в одно предложение, я к счету, ну, у меня нет вопросов.
ты окей если ты сильный если ты обеспечиваешь если ты и дальше все что придет в голову но у
меня есть такие . я еще я же у меня не вкладывается у меня пластинка надо разблокировать быстро взять
расчесать да и придумать почему другие люди окей я понимаю что здесь сидит сильная женщина которая
сама решает все свои вопросы мы все очень этим горды теперь надо проанализировать другим людям
какие у меня критерия я например трудолюбивая и я считаю что люди окей если они трудолюбивая
я трудолюбивая если люди не трудолюбивая не тоже окей и окей трудолюбивые и окей не
трудолюбивым не уже какая благодать но вот прям вот просто вот не они я понимаю где-то подвох как
разлакировать но я не знаю настюш нам не сложно представить себе этот я знаю что я точно вот если
ко мне кто-то придет я задаю вопрос от и трудолюбивый человек муж и я понимал он
попадет моя ценность если он попадает моя ценность и мне с ним легко ну например я
своих студентов спрашиваю вы любите учиться этому подойти вопросу тогда по ценности твой не твой ну
конечно окей он так руки если он и не мой тоже окей ну просто я у нас сейчас не вот это вот
знаете когда брата мира нам надо исследовать паттерны поведения тогда свой иногда с проекции
свой свой чужой можно все благодарю можно свой чужой но обычно супругом выкатывает или
возлюбленным ты окей если как сегодня мне один сказал мой клиент сказал но это же невозможно
невозможно говорит она все время от меня что-то ожидают я к ней приехал она говорит а по-моему
помой мне машину. А я говорю, да у меня
учёба, вот просто учёба,
учёба, я не могу. А чего
это ты не моешь?
Ну, то есть, окей, да, для этого человека,
если другой человек будет его понимать,
радовать другим.
Ты окей, если ты меня радуешь.
Ты окей, если
ты там дальше. И для каждого драйвера
есть какая-то своя особенность,
своё поведение.
Ну, или как Настя
говорит, свой-чужой.
И далее мы говорим про себя.
Я окей, если...
Далее записывайте то, что вам в голову прийдет.
В каком времени вы окей.
Это понятно?
Таким образом мы анализируем эти родственные послания.
И мы тогда можем понять, кто мы, как мы идем.
Кто есть нашим, кто есть чужим.
Что я вам сейчас хочу подарить? Я вам подарю опытовальник относительно драйверов, чтобы не сказали, что вы какие-то не такие, у вас есть все научные исследования.
Я такой опытовальник, Джулия Хейна, если бы ты его там придумала.
И вам потреб... Нет, Таби Каллер, прибрехала немножко.
Вам нужно сейчас ответить так или нет, или частично.
На так 1 балл, на нет 0 баллов, на частично 0,5 балла.
Задание понято?
Сейчас я вам выводлю на экран, и вы смотрите.
У вас, кстати, он должен быть в ваших раздаточках,
но все равно выведу.
Давайте
ответ на вопрос. Первое.
Чи приховываете, чи контролюете
свои почутся?
Лада, можете еще раз, пожалуйста, повторить
как рахунок?
Да. Один балл.
Нет. Ноль баллов.
Частково
ноль пять баллов.
Да. Вот все.
Смотрите. Оценивание. Все правильно.
Доброе. Погнали.
Відповідь на питання.
А перше питання. Чи приховуєте, контролюйте своё почуття?
Одразу пишите. Або 1, або 0, або 0,5.
Друге. Чи неохоче просите про допомогу?
Третье. Чи ставите высокие стандарты, а потом критикуете себя, если не дотримались этого?
Четвертое. Чи роботы для инших те, що насправді не хотіли б?
П'ятое. Чи маєте звичку робити багато справ одночасно?
Шостый. Чи не любите сдаватись, сподіваючись, що цього разу все вийде?
Сим. Чи важливо бути правым?
Висям. Чи важливо вам подобатись иншим?
Девять. Чи є вас тенденція почати і не завершити справу?
А 10. Че ставити нереалистичні, занадто короткі строки?
11. Че лагко вас прекунати?
12. Че не любите ви відрізнятися поміж інших?
13. Чи займайте позицию, де від вас залежать інші?
14. Чи дратують вас дрібні безлады, як пляма, річни на місці, неаккуратність інших?
15. Чи схильні ви бути нетраплячими та поспішати?
16. Чи не терпите, коли вас перебивают?
17. Чи часто поревнуете себе, работу с иншими и відчуваете зверхність або меншовартість?
18. Чи ходите по колу, не вирішуючи проблеми и не відпускаючи ее?
19. Чи не помечаете в томе, голоду, болю, все одно продолжуете працювати?
20. Чи одночасно говорите с иншими и закинчуете их фразы?
21. Чи любите пояснювати точно то у деталях?
22. Вы желаете сразу обратиться к делу вместо обговорки?
23. Вы отдаёте перевагу работать на одиночестве?
24. Вы не любите конфликты?
25. Вы имеете тенденцию бунтовать или отразиться от группы?
Так, заполняем баллы. Первая шкала «Будьте досконалыми». Рахуем ответы на вопросы. 3, 7, 14, 16, 21.
А если я просто писал колонки 3 и не знаю, к какому вопросу, мне еще раз прийти?
друга шкала радуй инших 48 а можно еще вопрос что я не поняла то есть я поставила баллы напротив
каждого вопроса а теперь первая шкала что такое 3 7 14 16 вопрос 3 вопрос 7 вопрос 14 вопрос 16
вопрос 21 мы суммируем баллы по этим вопросам так 3 7 вторая шкала радовать других радовать
Четыре, восемь, одиннадцать, дванадцать, двадцать четыре.
Третье, поспешай.
Пять, десять, пятнадцать, двадцать, двадцать два.
Четвертое, будьте сильными.
Один, два, тринадцать, девятнадцать, двадцать три.
И пятая, намагайся, постарайся, 6, 9, 17, 18, 25.
Там, где 3 балла и больше, что там, Настя, уже что-то прям...
Лада, повернись, будь ласка, слайд назад.
Сейчас поверну, без проблем.
Смотрите.
Дораховывайте.
Скажите, когда уже.
Настя, что там?
Эйфориэт успеха.
Уже сделали, девчата?
Так.
добре там поспешай буду сильным но сильно добре
за но тут и соби что там вас эксклюзивно вышло
цей опыта вольнок можно давать клиентам
влада мы фиксируем все что больше трех правильно да
И включаю еще три, нет? Три и больше трех. И три и больше, да. А какие были
остальные? В пятом. Перепрошу, что значит в пятом? В пятом какие цифры были? Какие
Девчонки, смотрите, сделайте себе скрин.
Або это должно быть у вас в раздатках, это я точно знаю.
Молодцы.
Как вы сейчас?
Я хочу на первом с драйвером поспешать.
Я хотела сказать, что первые, кто поспешает и сильный, они уже тест сделали, проанализировали, отрефлексировали, сидят ждут.
Да, послушайте, у каждой людины есть два, а иногда и три драйвера, которые дают риск этой поведенке.
пиццем плывом цех драйвере люди мать-я-кусь да да лен слуха и вот это прикольно будет сильно
вышло два с половиной там три с половиной четыре красиво а вот с точки зрения тоби колера у него
а у него все по-другому, он по-другому считает, у него другие опросники, он по-другому на все это реагирует, но есть так, как есть.
Так, ну что, мои хорошие, поспешать жить свое житие, да, бачу, все интересно у нас проявилось, все очень интересно, ничего страшного тут нет, короче, что мы с этим всем делаем, да, как нам дальше с этим всем жить.
Нам нужно, когда у нас есть эти драйверы, особенно сделать другим то, что от нас ожидали.
То есть в зависимости от драйвера мы должны себя так поводить.
То есть мы себя включаем.
И, например, если люди имеют драйвер радовать других,
Они часто кивают головой, поднимают брови, говорят «угу».
Такие добрые, хорошие люди, как я говорю.
Люди-сонечко, або такие хорошие парни, то есть с ними очень легко бывает.
И ключевая мотивация в этом драйвере, что люди чувствуют свою личную ответственность
и должны сделать так, чтобы другим людям было хорошо.
Для них важно, чтобы они понравились.
И уровень коммуникации с ними, мы про это еще не говорили,
но с этими людьми можно говорить про чувства и про думки.
Это то, про что они будут легко говорить.
Так, хорошо, давайте я вам покажу,
какие есть такие особенности,
то есть проявления, чтобы вы себе сделали такой скриншот.
Как по поведенцам, можно это все посмотреть.
Нахыляют голову, перебеждают.
Это радовать и других, радовать и других.
Сильно нахыляются, горблят плечи, идут вперед.
Если спина не болит.
Ой, Люточки, с этим разобрались.
Физический прояв подивилися, будете сейчас, ну, вы уже в мене разумны, вы одразу зрозумите,
яка людина радует, яка нет. Вы уже это чувствуете, да, тут не нужно до бабки ходить, все зрозумело.
Добре, что там у нас еще может быть?
В них, они завжды рятуют, частично за все.
И потом за это еще и могут преследовать других людей.
Какие у них есть забороны?
Я думаю, что это нужно также посмотреть и знать.
Это очень классно даст вам подсказку,
какие у них рэкетные почувствия,
какие у них аутентичные почувствия.
То есть сумма, заплутанность образа,
неразумение, смех.
А под всем этим гнев.
Заброна не чувствовать гнева
и не быть важным, не расти, не быть собой.
Иноди у цих людей є такі ігрові, чудові, штовхні мене або дурні.
Які є оці переконання? Люди думають, якщо я розлютюся на тебе, буду злий, то ти мене зречешся, кинеш,
И поэтому я буду радовать тебя и не показывать своих гнев.
Но сами по себе приглашают к критике, перебеждают, самодраматизируют.
Вот так.
Тут разобрались? Все понятно?
Есть какие-то вопросы относительно этого, или нет?
Нормально я рассказываю? Все понятно, я думаю.
Можно посмотреть, знаете, на таких кроликов из леса в Зазеркалье, он был с этим драйвером.
Так, что еще у нас есть?
А, нет, кролик из Зазеркалья, он у нас был и радовать других,
но этот кролик, если я его помню, он всегда был таким метушным.
то нам нужно посмотреть, как люди выглядят, например, с драйвером «поспешай».
Они очень быстро говорят, очень быстро.
Седают на край стола, всегда куда-то поспешают.
Знаете, как будто нет времени жить дальше своей жизнью.
Физический прояв.
Тело или голова нахилены вниз, вперед.
Постоянно меняют позы, крутятся, хитрают ногой.
может иметь бегающий взгляд, не успеваю, не успеваю, сейчас-зараз типовые такие фразы.
Это будет дополнительным, да?
Нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, это мотушевица, это поспешаться, девчата,
это то, что там в кого-то вышло, поспешаться.
Но и так я поняла, на мой взгляд, Таби Каллер так классно описал эти драйвера,
в таких классных названиях, что ты
сразу разумеешь, где ты находишься.
Чи не?
Извините.
Такой вопрос. У меня поспешай.
Но я медленно
говорю, я не сажусь на край стула.
То есть, со всех
физических проявлений
я не нашла у себя ни одного.
Хорошо. А есть какой-то
драйвер, который ведущий, Оля?
Ну, есть же у нас драйвер, который будет сильным, у меня самая мощная.
Ну, значит, у вас первое должно быть физическое проявление, а по драйверу быть сильным.
То есть по степени, как мы сегодня уже обсуждали, Оль, по степени интенсивности драйвера проявляются.
То есть, если, например, быть сильным на первом месте, то тогда наоборот.
Медленная речь, немного отрешённость, покер-фейс.
И это то, что будет доминировать.
Ага, пожалуйста.
Вот, так, что еще у нас?
Они чаще всего могут быть в роли с поспешай, переследующего, туда стартуют.
У них есть проблемы, они, тяжело им делегирование делать, да, и у них предчастный старт или запозднение с стартом.
Какие у них есть с этим драйвером рикетные чувства?
Смотрите, ажитация, такая радость, как она, как преимущественно, неосознанная.
То есть, они куда-то спешат.
Забороны не чувствуй, не будь близким, не належь, не будь здоровым.
Что им сложно пережить?
Они не ценят свободу в других людях.
Что ты так долго? Скажи скорее. Игры, как бы не ты, так, но чтоб не меня.
Что за игра, чтоб не меня, Влада?
Ну, пни меня. Помните, был такой у нас красивый семинар про игры, там, где я рассказала про одну парочку.
Там где Аня и Петя, у меня такие две дьяволы, Петя приехал к Ане в гости, первый раз пролил на скатерть каву, потому что он очень поспешил.
Второй раз, я не знаю, разбил Анин компьютер, потому что очень поспешил. Третий раз не ехал на Анину собачку, потому что очень поспешил.
Понял? Эта игра «пни меня», то есть осознанно человек ищет для себя,
потому что иногда она очень сильно спешит и иногда может сделать такую провокацию,
где ей будет больно, где она очень поспешила.
«Пни меня», что «пни меня». Это понял?
Да, спасибо, спасибо. Я уже головой боюсь кивать.
все накивай мне чтоб никто не дай знайся про насики у нас драйвера то что мы все свои наши
вы на справки ничего страшного тут не мая но царь люди це життя мы так адаптовалась а добро
живем он ничего страшного кивайте головой все у меня просто один вопрос висит если это убрать то
что же осталось в том этом проснулась ушла до ресницы то сеансе скидаду нет это так и у меня
в конце данную пропила в конце у него вопросы если это осталось то что же ушло интересно просто лет
ушел настя скелет ушел личность ушла знаешь на цена чем все держалось так вот мне интересно
Если это всё как шелуху распаковать чуть-чуть под это, то что вам останется?
Настенька, в этом смысл нашей жизни на самом-то деле.
Мы всё время ищем, какие мы, какой у меня скелет.
И не всегда у нас достаточно ресурсов отбросить эту мишуру, накладные ресницы и прочие вещи, которые есть в нашей жизни, чтобы понять, какая я.
У меня многие спрашивают, а как это, а как это?
Да всю жизнь ты ищешь, какой ты.
Не бывает, да, там словила, например, 30 лет инсайд или в 40 лет инсайд.
Каждый раз у тебя новый в жизни инсайд.
Я сколько живу, столько у меня новых инсайдов.
И уже думаешь, тут разобралась, тут разобралась.
А нет, вон уже, что стекала я.
Короче, это нескончаемая игра.
Ну, на мой взгляд, да.
Это такой джекпот, который мы словили на земле для того, чтобы пройти свой собственный апгрейд.
Юра.
Я бачу.
А как Влада отвечает себе сейчас, какая я?
Разное, Юра. Разное. Это то, что я могу ответить любому человеку.
Подошёл ответ?
Вот я только хотела сказать что-то.
Ну, интересно, какую-то более расширенную версию.
Ой, ну, Юра, только расскажу потом, после всех семинаров, да,
потому что если я сейчас начну рассказывать, это будет семинар про меня.
Мне надо обучить вас. Вот в этом-то вся история, Юра.
юра ну слова про себя давайте такой я гораздо повторю хомуха целый день об этом но хорошо
хорошо хватит идем дальше мои дорогие у нас куча дел я вам столько всего рассказывать хочу знаете
меня не остановишь, да, в моем стремлении обучить людей. Вам интересно, все нормально? Еще нет такого
тупняка перевантаживания? Еще держимся, да? Ну, хорошо, хорошо, давайте дотримаемся до конца. У нас сегодня
транзакционный анализ. Так, хорошо, что у нас дальше с физическими проявлениями? У нас же есть следующий драйвер,
будет «досконалом». Сейчас покажу, давайте. Кто, кому интересно, ну, вы же и сами можете
Зрозумите? Тобто ця оця досконалість, оці варсійнички, оці по-перші, по-другі, по-треті, шо я тобі скажу.
Тобто потрібно бути людям, і вони виглядають так акуратно, педантично, мовлення дикторське, щиткою структурою, номерація, очі дивляться в бік, ну короче, досконалість, все, аврал.
Потому что если недосконалый, то тебе пришел капец.
Роли переследователя снова.
Рекетные почувствия.
Фрустрация, гнев, провинсум.
Забороны. Не чувствуй смуту, не будь детьми, не радуйся, не будь близким.
Слушайте, игры «Скандал», попался «Сучий сын», «Загнанный», ну так, або «Штовхни» мне еще красиво называется, сучасно сейчас эта игра, «Загнанный», «Хыба» это, знаете, как «Кастыль», вот так называется эта игра.
И решение, импульс этой людины, она думает, если я не буду думать за тебя, что-то плохо станет.
Юля, все хорошо? Юль Кравчук, нормально, заходи.
Потому что я иногда на обличье смотрю, смотрю. Я думаю, клиент скорее жив или скорее уже мертв, да, что там уже вообще, есть ли коннекшн.
Там кто-то смотрит, кто-то кивает, кто-то смеется. Так, это вы понимаете?
Юля, драйверы не выдает. Юля, молодец.
Юля, ты сильная, что-то не поняла, да?
Какая?
Юля Кравчук.
Сильно? Сильно, да?
Я не знаю. Ну, откуда я знаю? Просто сидит эта людина, смотрит на себя. Мне нужно контакт установить.
Знаете, у меня недавно был экзамен в Америке, да? Там была группа, которую я учила.
И нужно с всеми научиться, показать свой стиль выкладывания, показать, что ты с всеми держишь контакт.
Но для меня это важно. Это мой стиль. Я люблю запитывать людей, как у них дела.
Вот, и я люблю, когда мне люди отвечают.
Хорошо, идем дальше. С физическими проявлениями. Поняли?
Вопросов нет? Все понятно?
Вот молодцы. Вот молодцы. Идем дальше. Что у нас еще тут есть?
Так, что у нас еще есть?
Значит, так.
Намагайся, мы уже проговорили, девчата?
Нет, было только будь досконалым, еще намагайся и будь сильным.
Ага, ага, ага.
Так, добре, намагайся.
Намагайся, это такая неухайность есть.
А сейчас покажу, есть намагайся, иногда есть неухайность,
есть напряжение. Сейчас покажу вам этот слайд, как физические проявления. Это не означает, что они
должны все быть, но иногда так будет. Иногда активные жесты, а потом стихают. Далее, рисуют что-то,
сморщивают брови, напряженные позы. Вот такая тут есть сморщика, вот такая. Люди намахаются,
потому что они очень сильно охмурятся, сильно намагаются, очень сильно. Иногда это можно
Я не знаю, не понимаю, постараюсь, пытаюсь. Буду пытаться.
Далее. Что у нас тут? Далее. А это уже быть сильным.
Так, относительно игр. Давайте я вам что-то.
У них пытаться. У них не очень хороший коннекшн с своими чувствами.
Да, потому что люди пытаются и пытаются.
Ну, как вы думаете, какие игры могут быть?
Также могут быть игры «Штопни меня», да,
то есть там такая колечко невеличкое.
Ну, так иногда бывает.
Люди пытаются достигнуть успеха, но его не достигают.
Это важно и это нужно понимать.
И с этим драйвером нужно работать.
И я вас на начале нашего обучения уже научила.
Не нужно говорить слово «я постараюсь» или «я пытаюсь».
Или «я буду», или «я не буду».
Да?
Ну и давайте на остаток, что у нас там осталось.
У нас остался драйвер «Будь сильным».
Что у нас есть для этого драйвера?
Есть нерухомость в позе, в обличье.
Монотонный голос, отсутствие жестов, дистанция.
Это неприятно, ты меня злишь, мне нудно.
Роли переследовача, первое.
Игры, никого не маю дома, ну, такая дистанция.
Оранжерея, деревянная нога.
Захистные механизмы, это диссоциация, втекание, изолированность.
И решение то, что было в них принято, то, что происходит, делает меня болезненными.
Поэтому эти люди, они остаются сильными.
Ух, я уже наговорилась.
Так, нужно сделать это и выгрузить контейнер.
Так, Лера, я же вижу руку.
Да, Влад, подскажи, пожалуйста, можешь показать,
что это мы пропустили, был физический прояв у «Намагайся»,
А вот это про ракетные чувства, защитные механизмы игр, где-то я пропустила.
А там очень плохо, это же пытаться, там нет контакта, Лир, с своими чувствами.
И его дальше мы будем изучать сценарий, его не будет в одном проявлении.
Вы также дальше увидите, но с тем временем это все.
Хорошо, слушайте, гений мой, давайте немного выгрузим контейнер
На 10 минут в парочке, по 5 минут в каждую сторону, кто что там нашел и что делать с этим всем.
Это хорошее вопрос. Что делать? Ну, ликовать. Сейчас научу.
Я буду указать, что нужно с этим делать. Давайте выгрузим шведенечко-контейнер.
10 минут. Давайте 10 минут на работу с этим.
Разделяю вас по парах.
Я так, как вы сказали, наговорилась, а я вот так, типа, наслухалась
очень много информации, и такая она, прям,
трешки, вот эта усталость такая
ощущается объемная информация да вы получаете за 8 часов а учение то что люди получают за
12 или 16 часов поэтому ну знаете под что подписались то и делаем ну держитесь еще
немного я немного вам сокращу этот материал чтобы вам было более интересно и легче его
далее, тут есть какие-то вопросы? Все поняли? Да? Что делать будем? О, снова что делать. Ну ты посмотри,
сколько этих поспешающих в нашей группе. Сейчас будем что делать, сейчас. Смотрите, есть бабушка у нас,
очень хорошая тетя Джулия Хэй. Дайте я вас с ней познакомлю. Джулия Хэй, она сказала, что есть два
боки драйверной поведенки. И тетя мала в цьому рацию, дуже гарно, тому що вона сказала, є робочий стиль,
а є драйверна поведінка. Що це означає? Робочий стиль, наприклад, людина сильна, якщо вона не
входить в патологію, тобто не дуже там, іноді може приймати допомогу, чимось займатися, да,
помогать другим, то есть как рабочий стиль.
Это красиво, это хорошо, это помогает нам жить.
Ну, например, быть досконалым.
Как рабочий стиль, например, мы следуем хорошо за тем, что у нас вокруг.
Втягиваем хорошую одежду,
быть сильными, достигаем меты,
радовать других, даем нормальный контакт с другими людьми.
Это рабочий стиль.
А драйверная поведенка – это когда уже патологический процесс.
Тут понятно?
Да, то есть не нужно сказать, что все драйверы – это катастрофа вообще на всю жизнь.
Нет, это не правда, это брехня.
Нужно просто идти не в патологию.
Хорошо, что мы будем делать?
Как выходить из драйверной поведенки?
Показываю.
У каждого драйвера что-то отдельное.
Радовать других.
Научиться спрашивать людей, что они хотят, вместо того, чтобы отгадывать их желания.
Когда там этот драйвер, пожалуйста, сразу пишите себе.
Далее, радовать себя, а не других.
То есть помечать свои собственные потребности.
«Навчитеся просить про то, что вам нужно».
И «тримать свои межи».
То есть сказать «нет», когда вас что-то просят сделать, то, что вы делать не хотите.
так так они выход из хорошей девочки что тоже можно не радовать других разрешить себе не разу
быть нехорошим вот нехорошая радует только себя такая как есть как есть это другое это про драйвер
каким-то говорили не будь собой до быть сильно здесь очень важно сделать акцент на том что вы
вместо того чтобы радовать других людей радуете себя так насть что-то только что получила просто
ответ на то почему я была удивлена потому что я думала что у меня один из драйверов и торну
радовать радовать других это прям явно проявленный драйвер а в тесте он не показался очень даже
заниженный показался и я сейчас осознала в том что буквально с недавно там какие-то вот полтора
прежде чем радовать других рады себя на тип прежде чем что-то сделать другие сначала себе и я этим
вопросом стала останавливать меня есть импульс сейчас помогу потом сначала себе помоги потом
пойдешь получается что этот драйвер он как бы уже проработан поэтому в тесте сейчас он показал такой
ну минимум да наверно так это не может не радовать хорошо хорошо разве это плохо я считаю что это
хорошо а так далее дам обуты досконалым будь то досконалым коза
а то кто треба рубить и реалистичнее стандарты я кости то точности да я
завжди кажу а ну мы мы на досягнем у тигей досконалости тут дуже сильно
люди себя карают за помылки.
То требует, когда
людина сделала эту помылку,
спросить себя,
что это действительно так страшно.
Людям,
другим, сказать нормальную фразу,
что твои помылки,
они не критичны.
И что помыляться, то нормально,
потому что это можно
исправить. Главное,
донести до себя
да, до клиентов, что
каждый из нас имеет право
на ошибку, и делать эту
ошибку, это не сомнительно.
Это понятно с доскональностью?
Слушайте, такие
изгадали историю с
психотерапевтической практикой,
был у меня клиент
очень досконалый, ну, такой просто, ну, красный,
да, уровень бога, как я говорю,
что приходит, все, белая рубашечка, сурочечка,
там все, ну, красиво, ну, девчата,
ну, все очень хорошо подобрено, очень красиво.
И он, ну, хотел как-то перепрацировать этот драйвер.
И один раз он решил сделать что-то недосконалое.
Ну, человек же недосконалый, он пришел вот в таком, ну, я не знаю, там,
такая ветровочка была на эту красивую сурочку,
он взял ее, вывернул и пошел с кабинета,
в ветровке на вывороте.
Он сказал, что это был
самый сложный свой путь,
который он доехал домой.
Потому что он был такой недосконалый.
То есть давать разрешение
сделать что-то недосконалое.
В следующий раз пришел в разноцветных носках.
Тренировал себя.
То есть давать разрешение
сделать что-то недосконалое
другим людям. Это понятно?
Хорошо.
Далее, что у нас, какой у нас драйвер?
Будьте сильными.
Что нам сделать?
Ну, во-первых, нужно складывать реалистичный такой кейс
относительно работы, которую я должен делать.
И не делать всю работу света самостоятельно.
Это очень важно.
Просить про помощь.
Про помощь.
Учиться делегировать все то, что есть, и все то, что можно сделать, передавать другое, это очень важно.
Далее, учиться признавать свою слабость и сказать, что это нормально, это нормальная часть жизни.
и учиться распознавать свои процессы, свои потребности.
И понимать свои потребности как физические, так и психические.
То есть давать и установить контакт с собой.
Так, с этим разобрались, идем дальше.
Намагаться.
Припустить, вызвать добровольцем там, где на все проекты, которые есть в этом жизни.
Складывать план там, где завершены задачи.
Далее, проверять условия задания.
И что нужно делать, чтобы это задание фактически выполнить.
Записывать идеи и дать этим идеям возможность побывать в процессе.
Не сразу бежать, я буду это делать.
а немного побудь в процессе, как дозреть им нужно.
И выучить, решить свои проблемы самостоятельно,
брать ответственность за свои действия.
И последнее – поспешить.
Важно слушать других, позволять им закончить их думку, планировать работу поэтапно.
Ну, повольно говорить, это нужно просто взять себе как тренинг.
Зрозумите свою вторинную винограду, когда человек бежит вперед.
Может, не хочет проживать человек теперешние чувства, поэтому он бежит вперед.
И нужно чувствовать и быть тут и сейчас.
Как вы, как для вас эта история относительно, ну что делать?
У меня такое впечатление, даже если я нахожу, типа со мной не окей,
и все равно сижу и думаю, что со мной все окей. То есть, типа выход из этих сценариев, а я понимаю,
что ну зачем тогда я потерял свою аутентичность так ну давайте я расскажу зачем до чтобы вы
понимали какая будет финальная расплата у каждого драйвера есть своя финальная расплата скажу просто
и прямо каждый драйвер не зря говорят это мини сценарий это какая-то особенная стратегия особо
И в каждого драйвера есть своя финальная расплата.
Первый. Начнем с радоваться другим.
Человек дает очень много радости другим.
Потом она втомляется.
И она начинает всех переследовать.
Потому что она ожидает, что другие люди будут радоваться ей.
Но давайте вернемся в реалии жизни.
Если кто-то тебя радует, ты что, остановишь эту людину, скажешь, нет, больше мне радости не дай, давай я тебе сделаю что-то приятное.
Сгадайте, пожалуйста, какие-то родственные отношения. Там, где мама всегда приносила, ну, я не знаю, такая патриархальная родина, снеданок ставила всегда на стол и годовала всю родину.
Что, хоть один раз кто-то вышел с утра и сказал, мамочка, родная, китя моя, не ставь снеданок на стол?
Или давай я тебе приготовлю еду, но может один раз кто-то и сделал, по жизни никто не сделал.
У меня еще до сих пор клиентка, ей уже 65 лет, она ставит эти снеданки своему человеку.
И только она один раз проспала, что сделал он ей.
Смотрел на нее, как на врага.
Сказал, чего ты мне снеданок не сделал.
То смотрите, человек, который радует других на 8 березня.
Ну так, один раз на год можно.
Когда человек радует других, она втомляется,
переследует других, и потом, когда она втомлена,
Або она хвореет, потому что она задоволена радоваться другим.
Кстати, эта клиентка захворела на рак.
Або начинает преследовать, бунтовать, сказать, а с кем я должен ехать, готовить.
Все зависит еще и от культуры.
Далее.
Быть сильным.
Люди, которые должны, драйвер, быть сильным.
Финальная расплата.
Ой, Юля, мне так жаль, да, если через это все прошло,
я не хочу, чтобы люди проходили через какие-то плохие ощущения
или прочувствовали это жизнь.
Так, дальше.
Быть сильным.
Человек не может побудовать на самом деле близкие отношения с другими людьми.
Она чувствует самотность.
Финальная расплата, когда людина сильная, она на себе все втягивает, втягивает, втягивает, втомляется.
Заканчивается ее жизнь перечасно, потому что, знаете, как маленькая лошадка.
Втомилась.
Померла перечасно, потому что все делала или делала все сам.
И помер, потому что втомился все делать сам.
Клиентский случай.
Человек был очень хорошим человеком, был очень сильным и сказал, ну что вы там ломаетесь.
Тянул на себе работу, город, детей, все.
Помер.
Потому что утомился на себе все тянуть.
И люди умирают самотными.
У них есть чувство, что их так, и никто не понимал в этом жизни.
ну чему утробится все изменила наверное просто у меня уже то что проработан может быть я жду
меня но я веду к тому что меня это не так сильно триггерин да вот и как бы придерживаться что все
в принципе люди делают ради свои выводы то есть если и хочется радовать она же от этого получает
кайф когда она видит эмоцию она не получает кайф когда того кого она радует ну скупой на эту эмоцию
он не радуется тогда она понимаешь ну не туда не в ту сторону надо значит поменять объект кого
радовать чтобы получать в ответ вот и то есть если я например хочу кого-то радовать и человек
не радуется но я просто его перестаю радовать я радую других которые дают мне фидбэк вот и так
наверное во всем то есть если я не вижу выгоды в том что я делаю для себя эмоциональной историчность
скажем так я не пытаюсь выкладываться дальше у каждого по-разному они кто-то она и разыскивает
себе нового партнера для радости а кто-то глубоко жена да например он не может уйти из этих отношений
он тогда учиться как радовать не других а как радовать себя каждый просто прорабатывает это
проработано это чуть наверно проработано все же такая у меня был хороший психотерапевт лучше или
был или есть порадуемся да так хорошо насть продолжение по поводу сильный только что в
комнате только обсудила что вспомнила шкалу который выдавали про общение да и в этом стадии
интимности и вот эти сильные они не доходят стадии интимности а недавно буквально на сессию у меня
была такая сессия на супервизии и там был просто фееричное какое-то наслаждение кайф просто как
и я поняла что это как раз было вот это общение стадии интимности я вкусила мне понравилось я
теперь этот процесс не остановлю нужно открываться самому и не быть таким сильным но это вот полное
доверие было ну конечно что в безопасности доверия выстрелиться то есть это она это
непередаваемое общение до непередаваемая но опять-таки же надо времечко чтобы научиться
его устанавливать да потому что тяжело проявлять с драйвером быть сильным свою
уязвимость это правильно тут я еще прочитала комментарии очень смешное такие от работы дух
духнут кони но я бессмертный пони так вот очень славненько подтверждаем драйвер быть сильным так
хорошо ли мне кажется что вот эти драйвера они наверное включаются в каждой жизненной ситуации
свой включается если вот взять например пришел черт на массаж я понимаю что я не помогу этому
человеку то мне проще от него отказаться они стараться убеждать что я вот вам помогу или
например в этом случае пришел человек с драйвером быть совершенным и ты уже априори ему никогда не
сможешь помочь ну каждый вот этот драйвер жизненной ситуации наверно проявляется у
человека по-разному у каждого по-разному согласно ли но здесь просто надо понимать какой у меня
драйвер что я люблю и работать со своим драйвером да дальше уже помощь не поможь как бог даст а
давайте я вам расскажу далее чем все может закончиться но добавлю
трошки тела драматизма хочет очень и треба будь и досконалым людина будет
себя, всю жизнь
карать за то, что она
недосконала.
То есть это внутренняя самокритика.
И она будет
переследовать как себя,
так и других. То есть с этой
людьми будет очень тяжело,
ну, с такими людьми тяжело жить.
Потому что ты никогда не будешь
досконалым.
Ведущая себя
как этой людьми, так и
в тех, кто с ней находится.
Тем самым
она блокирует контакт
с другими людьми.
Намагаться.
Людина
не достигнет успеха,
чтобы она не делала.
Потому что она все
намагается.
Намагаться это не делать.
То есть, в кроке, в одном кроке от успеха, она или
зельется, или заболеет, или еще что-то случится.
И далее последнее – поспешить.
да да да там на ешь и финальная расплата съехать из разума вот так вот так а и не
думала и интересный транзактный анализ требует подчинитесь так ну так грунтовно и тут вы меня
и так и выкатывает это я подумаю конечно не бы богата всего роботе одночасно до
людина поспеша и тут поспеша и тут поспеша и тут поспеша я тело и нервовая система не вытримай а
Это я. Ой, Юль, ну что такое?
И ты тогда, ну знаете, девчата и хлопцы, ты живешь как на экономии ресурсов.
То есть, а есть, если драйвер один, прикрывает другой, боже, сидишь, распутаешь все жизнь, да?
И сам с собой работаешь.
Но сейчас вы уже знаете, что делать с этим всем.
Додала вам драматичного перца.
Почему это так?
Чем все заканчивается?
Мне нравится клиентам сказать,
давайте подумаем, какая будет финальная расплата.
Тогда сразу просветление.
Люди уже понимают, до чего они придут.
И все, и будет катастрофа.
То она сразу изменится.
Так, Леш, сейчас почитаю.
Ты тогда выходишь и не отдыхаешь.
2.4 на 7,
да, так оно и есть.
У каждого есть своя финальная расплата,
и очень тяжело. Иногда не отдыхаешь,
иногда не чувствуешь,
если есть драйвер быть сильным.
Ты не чувствуешь, что у тебя есть в доме.
Катастрофа.
Катастрофа. Все.
Что еще можно делать за классикой
транзакционного анализа?
У нас есть несколько вещей.
Мы уже сегодня с вами говорили
про дозволы. Зараз я вам покажу,
что там у нас взагалі можна робити
з цією класикою.
О!
Дивіться, є дозволи
до кожного драйверу.
Зараз покажу.
Ну, це знаєте, як
собі такі
афірмаціі написати,
по всьому дому розвішати
і ходити і читати.
Дивіться.
Пишите себе аффирмацию, повторяйте.
Ты достаточно хороший.
Можно быть собой.
Можно помыляться.
Это для досконалого.
Вот так себе записочки за нотаточки.
Сделайте на компьютере, с чем вы там работаете.
И на это посмотрите.
Или, как я люблю сказать, сделайте себе заставку на телефон.
Сто раз дивишься на тот телефон,
на 101 уже в тебе будет просветление.
Так,
дальше у нас. Радуй
других. Радуй себя.
Кажи
«нет» и спирайся на власть.
Радуйся на свою думку.
Будь сильным.
Говори про то, что хочешь.
Проси про
допомогу.
И знаете, как я
Сказать про то, что у тебя есть какая-то сладость, это про твою вразливость.
Это про большую силу.
Потому что только сильные люди, они могут показать свою вразливость.
Потому что ты же не знаешь, какие другие люди на это будут вообще реагировать.
То есть показывать нужно свою вразливость.
Так, что тут у нас еще люди говорят?
Старайся.
Заместо старайся,
сруби, або не сруби.
Завершуй.
И иди маленькими кроками.
И поспешай.
Не поспешай.
Маешь право на свой темп.
Та живи зараз.
Гений мой,
как вам дозволы?
Оновить заставочки на телефоне.
Как вы зараз?
Все нормально? Все добре?
Фух.
Ну, это мы какие-то, я не знаю.
Драйверы быть сильными, может быть, в каждом из нас.
Добре, давайте. Я таки истоньки хочу.
Я зараз уже не могу, девчата.
Я уже помру от голода.
Давайте пойдем на 5 минут раньше и вернемся, да?
Давайте 56-57 минут.
Давайте повернемся.
Восемь минут наступного часа.
Восемь минут.
Всем вкусного.
Повернемся.
Боже, какая благодать в этом жизни.
что нужно для радости. Счастливой быть, только поесть. Какая я прагматичная женщина, только еду,
только еду делает нас счастливыми. Как вы, успели поесть, попить? Нормально? Я даже чай себе
не сделала холодный. Ну, хорошо, ничего, хорошо, что сытая. Есть какие-то вопросы? Дожевываем все,
Все. Видите, как драйвер
будет сильным.
Так, доедаю
до вас. Давай, Аня, давай.
Доедай до нас.
Только не ешь ничего
вкусного, потому что сейчас полезу до тебя
что-то там пригощаться, что там у вас есть.
Может, уже холодильник
сховала все.
Добре.
Ой, Людочки, добре.
Так, вопрос есть?
Нет?
Нет? Все понятно?
Все поняли? Все хорошо?
Хорошо, какие вы у меня понятные.
Сейчас подумаю, что мы будем делать.
Мы будем сейчас с вами изучать шесть сценарных процессов. Готовы? Нет? Что? Не готовы?
Я уже запуталась, понимаете?
Ага, запуталась. Так, что мы сегодня изучили? Ну, люди добрые, давайте, скажите, что вы сегодня изучили? Чего я вас научила?
12 заборон, 25 заборон, 5 драйверов.
Молодцы, то где заплутались?
Все нормально сказали.
Так, а сейчас мы то, что выучили, будем с вами выучать как сценарные процессы.
Сейчас я вас научу.
Сейчас, секундочку, начну учить.
Значит так, начинаем выучать сценарные процессы.
Что такое сценарные процессы?
Это то, что происходит с нами, и у нас есть за Берном шесть сценарий в процессе.
Сейчас я вам их покажу.
То есть такие мини-сценарии это называется.
Пока нет.
После.
Никогда.
Да они у вас есть, Снежан. Я думаю, что они вас стоят отсюда.
Нет? Да что такое?
Никогда.
Сейчас научусь, все вы будете знать.
Завжди, майже и открытый конец.
За Бердом у нас были несколько сценариев.
Никогда, всегда, после, пока нет, снова и снова открытый конец.
Все было заберно.
Без нового и снова.
А снова и почти появился таби-калер.
Сейчас буду объяснять, что это означает.
Эти зашифрованные такие штуки, пока нет, после, никогда, всегда, почти.
Транзакционный анализ – это сплошная какая-то история.
Это сплошные какие-то мифы, какие-то истории, какие-то процессы.
Значит, начинаем изучать сценарийный процесс, пока нет.
Показываю.
Уявите себе, что есть люди, которые думают, что что-то хорошее не станет,
пока не завершится что-то меньше хорошее.
Зараз покажу, як це відбувається.
Тобто людина думає,
що я зможу відпочити,
поки не дороблю все.
Чи є тут люди,
які ідуть відпочивати
тільки тоді, коли переробили всю роботу?
У нас это сработает,
пока смерть не разлучит нас.
Какой ужас.
Я утрирую.
Ну да, было.
Грешна была.
Грешна была, да.
Далее, дивитесь,
какая еще есть проблема.
Я буду счастливой,
пока не закрою все
вопросы.
Что, есть люди, которые закрыли
все вопросы? Нет.
То есть, человек
не дает себе разрешения
жить, пока не
закинчиться щось.
Те, що є в неї,
в її житті, але
вона собі завжди
знаходить щось там,
де вона не закинчиться.
Ну, не закинчила це.
Тобто, я не дозволяю собі родити,
поки не завершу
щось.
Як це формуються? Знаете,
все поговорки сделал дело гуляй смело пока не съешь борщ нельзя там конфетах да не съел борщ
нет конфеты нет конфеты вообще потому что еще за борщом есть второе блюдо все туды топ наши ботки
там а так нам казалось я поведенковые паттерны всех людей вон и по-перше с тем сценарием даже
часто контролируют. Они имеют иногда обсессивно-компульсивные действия, то есть что-то хотят сделать для того,
чтобы что-то потом произошло. У них есть трудоголизм, у них есть такие ритуальные мысли, то есть одни,
и другие, третьи, четвертые, и так до бесконечности.
И они такие еще трошки собаки-подозреваки.
То есть у них есть параноидные такие тенденции.
Звитки це все взялося?
Эрик Берн, він любив досліджувати мифы.
И он взял и использовал эти мифы для того, чтобы объяснить эти сценарии.
И с этим пока нет, был свой связанный миф.
Геракл не мог попасть на Олимп, пока не выполнил 12 подвигов.
И хотя Геракл родился героем, все жизнь он вытрачал на доведение права на бессмертие.
Все жизнь хотел вражать других людей.
Потому что так требовала история его рождения и ревности Геры.
Так и люди с сценарием «поки не», «шо дня проживают микроверсию цього паттерна».
И это означает, что нужно еще немного потерпеть перед тем, как жить.
когда на рождество накрывали стол да и тогда говорили пока звезда не зайдет кушать нельзя
реклама была такая до первой звезды нас и в религии получается воспитывают пока что нет
да есть у нас религиозный культуральный родитель который тоже имеет на нас огромное влияние да если
не родителя значит религиозно а если не религиозно то значит общество может влиять на терпению
я думаю что выживанию и счастью даже больше несчастью выживанию то есть ты никогда не
будешь счастлив потому что ты должен быть счастливым только после выполнения каких-то
определенных условий но эти условия не всегда появляются в твоей жизни это никогда не будет
счастливым. Ты не можешь
радоваться, ты не можешь получать удовольствие,
ты не можешь
жить полной жизнью, пока не
кому выгодно, чтобы
не было несчастливого.
Если даже на уровне
религии, да, мифологических
историй, эта история
длится годами, веками
на протяжении всего человечества.
И с частным человеком легче управлять.
Ладно, это сейчас философия
начнется. С частным
человеком легче управлять счастливыми или управлять да ну вот ну вот в них есть своя
особливого мова да то кто ван и говорит сперва потребно а потом все что из потребно и людина
может себе как дополнительно вставить какие-то условия еще и еще и еще и еще есть условные паттерны
если только тогда еще пока нет сначала нужно то есть можно понять что человек она использует
эти паттерны для того, чтобы подтверждать свой сценарий.
Кого-нибудь отгадайте, пожалуйста, из своего оточения, в кого есть такой сценарий.
Есть? Юля, да? У меня? У Юли сегодня сценарий такой.
Ой, мне жаль. Все есть. Далее идем до следующего сценария, который есть.
это процесс «после».
Это, наоборот,
обратный процесс
от «пока нет».
То есть, сфиксация
не на расплате, а люди
не верят, что за все хорошее
нужно платить.
«После» что-то мне прилетит.
И есть свои особые паттерны поведения.
То есть, человек, ну, такая, знаете, она в тревоге живет,
потому что она всегда ожидает, что будет после.
Она нададаптуется к другим требованиям, потому что ей страшно.
Она такая эгоцентричная, она может быть зависима.
Бо е о цей стан писля.
Писля шось зе мною відбудеться.
Я таки вырос, да моклов меч.
И образ бов, да мокл.
Для цього сценарию.
Это был счастливейший царь, но когда он сам сел на трон, над ним висел меч на киньской волосине.
И вот это ощущение страха, что то, что у тебя есть, оно очень хитрое и оно может закончиться.
И люди не могут радиться, потому что когда они порадовались, это сегодня ты радуешься, а завтра плачешь, такие были выразы, такие были высказывания родителей, у тебя всегда будет покарание.
У кого есть такие?
Заново, да, Юль?
Доброе.
Так бывает.
Подумайте, пожалуйста, что вам сказали ваши родители,
если эти сценарии в чем-то отгукаются.
Какие были типовые фразы?
Чего ты радуешься, что день рождения?
Между прочим, да.
Не смейся, будешь плакать.
Смеется, только смеется встанет.
Молодцы, что еще люди вам сказали в вашем детенстве?
Скажите, я немножко сомна, да,
когда ты уже понимаешь, как оно,
оно так очень постепенно,
Никому ничего не скажи, что что-то случится. Все, что занадто, не здраво. Да, да, очень много чего было.
От этого становится невероятно грустно, потому что ты понимаешь, что тебя программировали твои родители.
И вот это осознание, что если я сегодня породил, то завтра я могу, должен за это заплатить.
Если у меня что-то доброе сегодня произошло, то завтра ко мне придет покарание.
Ты не мог просто этого.
За тобой придут и возьмут.
А если ты ещё что-то взял или что-то там чуть больше имеешь, чем другие,
то можно и на Сибири сухари досушивать оставшуюся жизнь.
И это просто агент выживания, который передаётся из поколения в поколение.
Да, это правда.
Тоже так же было.
Вот мы там в детстве смеёмся, рыбочем, я бы даже так сказала.
Потом кто-то падает, коленку сбивает.
То есть это не от родителей покарание пришло.
Но, тем не менее, ты связку вот эту логическую,
то есть поржал, посмеялся, с ума сошёл,
потом обязательно будешь плакать.
Ну, как бы так и было, к сожалению.
Но перед этим родители часто говорят такие вещи, нарративы,
а мы воспринимаем их нарративы как самоисполняющееся пророчество.
Если родитель без конца ходит и рассказывает,
не смейся, будешь плакать,
то спустя время ребёнок уже сам подыскивает себе то,
что подходит под его линзу.
настолько заигрываешься вот у меня сейчас конкретные такие флешбеки идут то есть ты
заигрываешься там кого-то толкнул кто-то упал начинает плакать ну вот эта качели от сумасшедшей
радости к печали но она как бы существует потому что когда ты вот этой эйфории ты получается себя
не контролируешь но по факту может быть и так детства вот детские вот эти шалости которые
смех радость и потом они обязательно кто-то чем-то удариться или базу разобьем или еще
и подтверждали эти паттерны типа я я же говорила я предупреждала
очень-очень поверишь да но что если глобально копнуть то все равно на ген
выживания от социума не передавали но из лучших побуждений
вот дальше выжил прожил в тех условиях которые есть вот но это здорово конечно когда мы это
начинаем осознавать но не всегда там ген выживания нас утешает самое главное что мы повторяем эти
паттерна да и надо от ней дальше избавляться ну да вопрос что помогает ли он тебе сейчас данный
момент или он тебе мешает если помогает то оставляешь а если мешает то делаешь хочешь
дано состояние радости одно тоже вот что за нато то на здраво потому что когда мы в состоянии
радости она тоже может иметь негативные последствия если мы в этом состоянии принимаем какие-то
решения то есть когда мы на эйфории когда мы радуемся но есть такая пословица да не принимай
решение когда ты счастлив потому что можно быть раздарить а потом жалеть там раздарить принять
какие-то решения пообещать что-либо потом как бы об этом жалеть и сожалеть поэтому тут тоже
есть такой момент что не всегда радость это стопроцентно положительное качество
да я думаю что все зависит от установок от того кто как воспринимает и опять-таки же то что мы
сегодня говорили про степень до этих запретов которые формируются у нас от родителей добрый
Продолжаем дальше. Процесс никогда. Я никогда не смогу получить все, что хочу.
Или оно недоступно, или это очень сложно. И человек сам создает условия, которые достижения делают невозможными.
Или какие-то повторенные скарги, или над какие-то идеи, которые вообще достигать, это невозможно.
но живет с большими фантазиями о том, что это может быть
возможно.
Основные есть паттерны поведения, закрытость, грандиозность
иногда, эти фантазии бездействия, экстремальность, пассивная
агрессивность, шизоидность, иногда антисоциальность.
То есть, это так, то, что может быть.
Как вы что-то нашли там в себе интересное?
У меня сейчас как раз рефлексия от Анны слов, даже с религией тоже связана.
Потому что Западная Украина, там больше идут вот эти все церкви, религии, да, ты уже родился грешный, и потом даже, когда вот этот пист и так далее, то есть нас научили рефлексовать над тем, что-то обдумывать, типа, но все равно нас повертали, там, не смейся, ты это, так, так, то есть какие-то навязывали уже, что ты никто, у тебя звук никак, и ты там можешь страждать, и все.
Ты родился, чтобы страдать, и пришел сюда, чтобы страдать.
Ну, как-то таки были даже неосознанные вот эти повторенные действия,
из которых сейчас как раз и выходите.
Да, оно так и есть.
И это и есть вот этим мифологическим образом Тантал.
То есть, сейчас я покажу, как это произошло.
Бог, влюбленность богов, который зловживает привилегиями и попадает в пекло и мучается.
То есть вода подходит к губам, но исчезает.
Плоды нависают, но отдаляются.
Так же и человек с процессом Николы желает, но не позволяет себе взять,
потому что эта оборона взять сильнее.
То есть никогда не буду счастливым, никогда не достигну того, чего захотел, никогда не получу то, что для меня важно.
Кто там такое знал, нашел в себе?
Можете себе это как-то выписать, потому что люди с этим сценарием думают, что не можно изменить долю.
я хотела бы изменить, но это невозможно.
Что-то вы таки сомневаетесь в мне?
Что-то слишком много информации, да? Такой негативной, немножко, ну не про меня, у меня было все, а кто сказал, в смысле, да, перепроверка, реальность, окей.
У меня даже вот типа раба божья, да, у меня всё время было, с детства, в смысле раба, кто сказал, я дитя божье.
Ну хорошо.
Дети говорят, что мы дети божьи, откуда тогда рабы, подождите, что-то у меня не застыковка.
То есть вот прям у меня, ну у меня вообще к религии очень много вопросов, очень.
Ну да, у каждого своя история бывает, но иногда она на нас может болезненно влиять.
Так, наступный процесс «завжды».
То есть, человек изменяет одни незадовольные условия на другие незадовольные условия.
И потом говорит, почему «завжды» это все повторяется снова и снова.
Одно плохо, а не другое плохо.
Третий шлюп с алкоголиком.
И человек остается так же, в тех самых ощущениях, но в других отношениях, в другом месте.
Людина начинает с одной думки, перескакивает на другую, потом на третью.
То есть думка стремится, нет последовательности.
Людина не анализирует ситуацию, как она дошла до этого.
А просто задает вот это вопрос.
А почему это всегда происходит со мной?
Почему это повторяется со мной?
И как основные паттерны поведения, это спивзалежность, это, возможно, нарциссизм, пассивность, внутренний хаос.
И был мифологический образ, это арахна, такая собиткаля,
которая кинула выклик Афине, програла, захотела повеситься,
Афина сняла ее с петли, но перетворила на паучиху.
Живи непокирно, ты будешь вечно висеть и вечно ткать.
Такая сумная история.
Вечность, почему это со мной снова и снова происходит.
И не имеем возможности что-то изменить.
И вот эта главная думка, да, всегда это со мной происходит, почему оно со мной происходит, чтобы я не делал, это никогда не изменится.
Частично за все эти люди негативно ставятся к окружению, берутся за большее, чем могут сделать.
обрывают контакты фразой «Да, мне это неинтересно, не очень хотелось», то есть оценивают.
И оценивают ситуацию, в которой находятся, и снова и снова возвращаются в ту самую ситуацию, потому что не анализируют то, что произошло.
И Берн объяснил возникновение такого поведения тем, что отец рассказал, например, своему ребенку так, что это невозможно сделать.
И ребенок часто может подумать, что я этим не впораюсь и не буду счастливой.
Вот я раздумываю и теперь понимаю, что в Италии так много депрессивных, ну это очень высокий процент, и когда сотрудничали с ними, то у них сразу, вот когда идут эти паттерны, в принципе, это же по паттернам, чтобы дать человеку на рефлексию и вывести с этого, у них сразу тревожно-депрессивный стан, депрессия, таблетки,
То есть за приглушение, и тут это очень высокий процент такого.
Ну то есть культурально есть такое признание, что никогда с этим не да.
Типа ты сам не справишься и так далее.
Хорошо, еще есть два процесса, почти один и почти два.
Это очень перекликается с теми драйверами, о которых мы говорили.
При почти одном сценарии.
Человек видит свою цель, но немного не достигает этой цели.
То есть она доходит почти до финиша и потом все это взрывается.
Паттерны поведенки.
«Людина бажает все и одразу. Вечный ремонт, несконченные проекты.
Тут есть у нас еще межовый развод, может быть нереалистичная, нарциссистичная стратегия.
Мне мало, хочу больше.
Можут быть антисоциальные какие-то проявы.
Майже, майже, майже, майже».
И я, ну, при этом, смотрите, что еще, как можно понять, да, что почти один. Вот, например, вы слышите своих клиентов, а они вам говорят, о, у меня есть несколько профессий, но ни одной профессии я не реализовала.
Я и тут, и тут, и тут.
Або есть много начинаний.
Там почти школу для детей открыла,
но она что-то не пошла.
Я ее закрыла, потом снова открыла.
Еще можно почувствовать и понимать,
что когда появляются трудности или испытания,
человек все взрывает.
И вот это подкрепление страха через покарание, через это проклятие, я никогда не смогу достигнуть конца.
То есть, человек не видит, где ее конец, где она заканчивается.
И тут есть интересный образ сизив.
Сейчас кто-то тебя увидит, возможно, да, это касается и счастья, и работы, и всего.
Сидел, он поднимал камень на гору, но камень скочил сам перед вершиной, и он обязан был начинать все с начала.
Засилия есть, результата нет, и я почти достиг успеха.
И вот этот оптимизм не очень здоровый. Если что-то пойдет не так, я всегда могу начать все с начала.
Что, нашли что-то интересное или не очень?
Мне так было, знаете, как-то подумать больше, мне больше, мне всегда драйвили забороны и драйверы, да, вот эта классика, она хорошая, красивая, но не всегда даже эти мифы, они отвечали реальностью.
Кто знает, кто не знает
цей миф, да, и там
что ты будешь пояснивать клиенту,
но для себя проанализировать
какие-то такие сценарные процессы
с Заберном, это интересно, ну просто
понимать, да, в кого там
завжди, в кого майже,
в кого пока нет.
Просто, ну так, немного развинуть
себя.
Вот.
И есть майже два.
Вот это, я думаю,
фишечка, сейчас вам всем зайдет.
У меня есть ощущение, что это как раз соответствует реалиям нашей группы.
И вот теория, вы видите, это я думаю про вас.
Человек достигает цели, но сразу ее не ценят.
И начинает искать новую цель.
То есть нет этого свята, этого фейерверка, этого празднования.
Нет этого кайфа.
И человек всегда ищет что-то новенькое себе.
То есть, человек не видит вершину, на которую поднялась,
и сразу ищет новую гору, чтобы снова стопить этот камень.
И тут частично за все то, что относится к нашей группе, иду дальше.
Не про то, что недостаточно, может быть у кого-то недостаточно,
Или можно было бы лучше, но я иду дальше.
То есть, тут есть еще фразы «життя то рух», «кто рухается, то и живет».
Иначе, нет времени для этого отдыха, для того, чтобы себя как-то довести к ладу и насладиться процессом.
Как вы думаете, почему я вам всегда говорю, как вы себя сегодня порадуете?
В каждом контракте.
Мы себя похвалили, вау, мы это сделали.
Оценили то, что мы целый день делали.
То есть, сфокусировались на действии, которая была нам сделана.
Мы сразу пошли бегать, а я то могла сделать, а я то бляха не успела, а что нужно, то сразу на себя накидать.
Потому что у многих из вас есть вот эта поведение, что вы оцениваете все то, что вы сделали, а обучение, тем более, я сама обучалась девчонкам в субботу и неделю, и это, как я говорю, я не знаю, как моя родина вообще выдержала это все, да, потому что это потеря, ну, ты, с одной стороны, потеряешь контакт со своей родиной на эти дни, да, ты очень много развиваешься, но это очень сложно.
Важно. Это очень важно. Когда ты как-то собрался, порвался, а когда 4 года, ты уже думаешь, что это капец. Это капец. Это просто капец.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, я вас прошу, себе еще раз поверните до того, что я вам сказала, как я себя порадую сегодня. Не можно не оценивать себя. Я не ваша мама, но я ваша тренерка. Я вас очень прошу, пожалуйста, вспомните об этом. Хорошо?
И основные паттерны поведения людей – это надмирный контроль, это служение, это такие, ну, тревожности иногда бывают.
И тут есть также свой мифологический образ, Кассандра такая себе была.
Сейчас покажу эту красоту, неимоверно.
Кассандра, она имела дар предбачения, но ей никто никогда не верил.
И этот дар постоянно оценивали другие.
но тут Кассандра каждый из нас или каждый из нас к себе, то есть люди не оценивают сами себя и
они говорят я не достиг успеха, я мало достиг желаемого результата, я мало делал, что там
там у кого есть, занотуйте себе, пожалуйста, если у вас что-то из этого есть.
Доброе, и открытый конец, мы уже про это говорили до этого на наших семинарах,
мы говорили, что людина живет до какой-то событий, а далее в ней открытый конец.
То есть, вот учусь или выучусь, а что дальше будет, невидимо, да, там, заканчиваю университет,
потому что человек дальше не видит своей цели и чувствует такую пораженную.
И есть какая-то точка, после которой все изменится, она не понимает, что она делает дальше.
С одной стороны, это и классный сценарий, открытый, потому что ты его можешь переписать,
Но это и не очень хорошо, потому что ты не можешь сфокусироваться и иногда понять, что тебе нужно делать.
Например, есть типовые паттерны поведения. Вечные студенты, пассивно-агрессивное поведение для них.
Иногда у них бывает такой синдром с порожнилого гнезда в родителях, например. Бывает очень тяжело.
И сложно с этим всем разобраться, и иногда нужно просто понимать, что будет дальше.
Иногда есть вот этот сценарий «рай не на бесах», то есть это сценарий не победителя, мы уже об этом говорили.
Это сценарий, в котором веноград приходит после смерти или после больших стражданий.
Или в этом жизни никто это не понимал.
Так тоже бывает.
Вот, и образ есть у нас до этого.
Фелимон и Бавкида.
Добрые люди, боги дячили им за благочестие и после смерти они перетворились на два дерева, что растут поруч.
Такие добрые люди.
То есть люди, которые выполняют родственные указания, люди, которые живут тихим, спокойным жизнью и люди, которые проживают такие растения и существования.
Доброе, мои хорошие, давайте трошки на 12 хвилин
зараз активуем энергию, подивимось, что вы там
познаходили в своих закромах.
У парах, будь ласка, поспілкуйтеся.
У нас слушатели.
Как вы? Что-то
познаходили?
Что-то отгукнулося?
Ну, трошки
такое, может, не дуже цикаве.
Але,
але,
девчата, вы ж не просто
так драйверы выучали.
Зараз в нас будет
джекпот, мы будем
удивиться, какие драйверы,
если вы не нашли
еще свои сценарии
за Берном, сейчас
найдете эти сценарии
за драйверами, да, то есть
подивитесь, потому что в каждой
человеке есть несколько,
ну, присутствующих, если честно,
почти все шесть, так, Юль,
слушаю.
Ладочка,
а мы сегодня будем целое занятие
шукать, может, давай ты их
лечить начнем я же сказала я клику вата шо я тут я же сказала да ему дозволы
нормально нормально такая тема знаете прямо сегодня пригрузила пригрузила я вас попереджала
что она вас перегрузит, девчата, что вы мне делаете, нужно же вас научить, ликуем через дозволы, да, повторить сейчас дозволы, дайте я вам расскажу,
потом будете уже повторивать свои дозволы и будете далее себе это все менять, хорошо, слушайте, в каждой человеке существует 6 сценарных процессов,
Но, как всегда, есть те, которые один основной и другой подпорядкованный.
То есть, немного меньше.
И это все проявляется у нас в дистрессе.
И вот сейчас я вам покажу, как драйверы проявляются в сценарных процессах.
Кто там свои таблички драйверов нашел,
сейчас, пожалуйста, себе занотуйте, какие у вас сценарные процессы.
Дивиться. Бути досконалым. Поки не. Гракол. Я не можу мати те, що хочу, поки не заплачу за це високу ціну.
Далі. Радувати інших. Після. Дамокл. Я можу радіти сьогодні, але завтра за це можу заплатити.
Бути сильним. Ніколи. Тантал. Я ніколи не отримую те, що хочу найбільше.
Замагайся. Завжди.
Арахна. Я мало не досяг успеху,
но снова и снова опынюсь в той же ситуации.
Радуй других. Плюс старайся.
Майже тип первого типа. Сизив.
Я майже досягну успеху.
Далее. Радуй других. Будь досконалым.
Майже тип 2. Моя роль закинчена, но я не могу остановиться, мне нужно идти дальше.
И смотрите, тут же код. Радуй других, будь досконалым, то поспешай. Это открытый конец.
Я достигнул цели, но не знаю, что мне дальше с этим делать.
Скажите мне, пожалуйста, ваши драйверы соединялись с вашими сценариями или нет?
Да.
Лада, я правильно понимаю, что ты говорила, когда мы начинали с «поспешай», его или в чистом виде нет, есть только с чем-то в паре, вот это остальное.
Да, да, радуясь, будь досконалым, поспешай. Так, чтобы это было что-то одно, нет такого.
Вот это про то, что я вам сказала, что немножко позже вы увидите это, и оно действительно так и существует.
Мы как раз с Леной в комнате про это поговорили, я тоже сказала, что из этого драйвера выходит вот этот сценарий процесс.
Ну, все вы отслеживали, только что как раз это, так что так и есть.
Да.
Отслеживали это.
Да, это хорошо.
Добре, слушайте, девчата и хлопцы, что я хочу сказать.
Еще до этих драйверов я поедала и казочки.
Потому что у нас, помните, были казки.
Попылюшка, ну всякие такие, да.
Сейчас я вам покажу, чтобы вы это уже запоминали на все життя.
Смотрите, какой интересный кейс.
Женский, мужчинский сценарий, да, в михвах и казках, да.
Женский вариант.
Покинь не попелюшка.
С первого года служения
награды только после
попробований.
И жизнь начинается, когда
случится какое-то чудо.
Далее.
После.
Белоснежка.
Счастье есть сейчас,
но над головой постоянно
мачеха.
Яблоко свои несет.
И всегда за хорошие моменты ждет какая-то расплата.
Никогда. Снеговая королева.
В жизни много покусок красы, но нет тепла.
Ка я себе забрала, женщина эта.
Никогда не можно позволить себе иметь то, что ты действительно хочешь.
И есть замороженные чувства и вот эта недостаточность.
Зажды, РМС, пустейный рух, хитрец, невловимость.
И в открытый кинет вы можете сами себе занотовать, это еще для вас и важливо.
Ладно, а где взять это? У меня что-то нет этих слайдов.
Сделайте себе скриншоты, смотрите, а зачем вам сценария?
Ну такие, вы же можете сами себе сесть и провести анализ, например, ваших сказок.
Это будет вашим домашним заданием и проанализировать, например, сказки «Золушка».
Какой может быть сценарий?
Мне никогда не нравилась эта сказка.
Ну, возьмите другую, я же не знала, какая нравилась.
Я предлагаю всегда взять свои любимые сказки и проанализировать.
Ой, гения моя. Добро.
То есть не будет, да, этой презентации, которая у вас сейчас?
Нет, презентации не будет, вы можете пересмотреть записи,
себе записать, если для вас это важно.
Добре, скажите мне, пожалуйста,
есть ли у вас какие-то вопросы относительно этого всего?
Все это понятно или не понятно?
Ладно, это я своим голосом.
Если у меня, например, червяная шапка,
Да, это же как раз про то у меня вылезло,
которое поспешает,
которое сильно и должно понравиться всем.
Все подходит.
Добре.
Вы хотели
немножко попрацевать над дозволами
и, возможно,
отрефлексировать над своими
сказками. Давайте, у вас есть
12 минут. Хочете, давайте
дозволы. Хочете, анализируйте
свои сказки.
Хочете что хотите, то и делайте свои на последние 10 минут для того, что в кого не завершено, завершите.
Добре?
И потом подведем подсумки и завершим наш семинар.
Потому что слишком много информации.
Я знаю, что вы втомлены.
Я вижу, что у вас много слушателей.
Если слушатели, то может не нужно делать?
Что у нас тут?
Сколько слушателей?
Лера, давайте тогда можем двигаться дальше, чтобы на это...
Давайте.
Если у нас слушатели, мы будем это делать. Если вам нужно будет давать себе разрешение, вы тогда, пожалуйста, в вашей группе можете их дать. Да, Лера, слушаю.
У меня вопрос. У нас есть техника, я не знаю, насколько ты с ней знакомишься, техника Тони Вайта.
Там, где мы спрашиваем клиента о его сказке, о любимом и любимом герое.
И он начинает рассказывать.
Может ли это нам также давать и сюда ссылку по этим сценариям, по этим драйверам?
Потому что по большому счету мы можем по-разному как-то трактовать сказки, мультфильмы, героев и т.д.
Или как ты это видишь?
Я думаю, что можно использовать, а скажите мне, пожалуйста, за техникой Тони Уайта, да, я бы не помню, что там, ну, я знаю, что он анализирует сказки, очень хорошо это знаю, скажите, есть ли такой, например, вариант, что в этой сказке человек перемещается в дополнительные какие-то символы, например, там, я, она есть попелюшкой, она есть принцем,
Она является тем главным героем, которым выделяет клиент, когда он начинает работать.
Ну, тут по великому рахунку, вот одна из первых.
Моя любимая история Лискасска в детстве была.
Да, «Людина продолжает».
Тут есть дополнительные вопросы.
Какая самая часть этой сказки тебя захватывала?
Кем ты себя представлял там, или оттожнил?
Ну, типа, есть вот эти дополнительные вопросы.
Нет, нет, нет, смотрите, чего нет, я уже поняла, чего у вас там нет.
Когда человек рассказывает вам эту сказку, слушайте ее очень внимательно.
И когда она голосом подсиливает какие-то фрагменты, например, там попелюшка готовилась к балу и ждала свою невероятную фею.
Вы себе занотовываете, пишет фея.
Або пишете принц. И далее вы можете запропоновать клиенту побыть в этих образах. Например, попелюшка.
Потому что это образы, которые могут принести вашему клиенту дополнительные ресурсы.
Мы берем за Тони Вайтом и рассматриваем только одну единую концепцию, как человек находится в этом сценарии или что он изменяется.
Но если есть подкрепление, подсиление каких-то основных образов, о которых говорит нам клиент,
представьте себе, какой будет офигенный ресурс, когда популя станет хорошей феей.
Потому что добрая фея, потому что это принц, потому что тыква, это все она.
То есть это будет вам добавлять еще больше ресурсов для изменения ваших клиентов.
И поэтому можно сказать, стань доброй феей, чтобы ты сама для себя хотела сделать.
Понимаете, о чем я говорю?
Да.
И тогда у вас есть расширение возможностей вашего клиента,
потому что все проговоренные слова
являются частью личности этого клиента.
Спасибо, очень интересно.
Ага, это вам так можете экспериментировать.
Хорошо, мои хорошие, какие у вас есть вопросы сейчас?
Что вам понятно, что вам не понятно?
Я поняла, что я вам рассказала, что есть в этом жизни дополнительное.
Хорошо, давайте я вам сейчас покажу, что у нас было сегодня на остаток.
Мы поговорили с вами про ОК-НОК батарею, поговорили про выдачу заборон,
даже взяли больше, чем 12 запретов, поговорили, как это происходит вообще в коучинге, в терапии,
поговорили про драйверы, про мини-сценарии, про сценарные процессы, и главное, драйверы и сценарный процесс,
как это все связать, чтобы вы не только имели частичку здесь, частичку здесь, а как это можно все это соединить.
Скажите мне, пожалуйста, что вы сегодня возьмете с собой, главное?
Во-первых, занотируйте себе, что для вас было главным.
А дальше, кто может, то и скажите.
Так, Ира, слушаю.
Влад, я еще хотела одно уточняющее
запитание. Что до драйверов.
У нас получается
пять драйверов, и один
идет тем ведущим,
и еще, даже если у нас идет
больше тройки, то они могут
подсиливать этого ведущего.
Это же не обязательно, что они пули, как
окремые драйверы, как
Он есть, но при каких-то обстоятельствах он будет сильнее включаться.
Например, быть сильным включается в отношениях.
Там, пытайся, может включиться в работе.
Да, потому что мы были с родителями и учились в наших родителях, как нам жить.
То есть, есть еще копинг-стратегии, которые мы себе сделали, ну, как нашу поведенку.
То есть каждый драйвер, он может в каких-то отдельных сферах жизни больше проявляться.
Спасибо. Что еще есть? Что вы с собой возьмете?
Лера, да. Знаешь, я начала писать в чат, думаю, чтобы на этот эфир не забирать сильно.
И понимаю, что я почти всю нашу сегодняшнюю лекцию, через кого пишу, и то взяла, и то взяла, но если это подсумывать, то, наверное, я сегодня под другим углом посмотрела на те вещи, которые где-то триггерят, где-то не нравятся, где-то есть вот это неразумение, чего оно так происходит.
И появилась возможность благодаря этому по-другому строить свои реакции, свое восприятие и то, как это можно переводить, наверное, в позитивный момент для себя.
Это классно. Переводьте это в позитивный момент. Это очень важно. Да, понимание приносит вам изменения и услышит.
Подбитие подсумков называется позитивным. Спасибо, потому что эти фразы, это такой характер, люди не меняются, не изменяются и так далее. Я понимаю, что это все были фейк-ньюс для нашего мозга подтверждения.
То есть все можно изменить, посмотреть, как и Валерия сказала, с другой стороны, с другой стороны, да, и взять большую силу с этого всего, даже, ну, тоже выбираем мы, то есть, в взрослую позицию, и кто делает выбор, и поведение. Главное, иметь осознанность, осознанность в том, что происходит.
Все классно. То есть, нет такого смертельного, все, ничего не выправляется, все выправляется, все нужно выправлять, что не нравится. Спасибо, Валерия.
Я согласна с вами. Слушайте, я вижу, что у вас этот семинар немного подгрузил.
Потому что очень много такой, знаете, экзистенциальной информации.
Потому что забороны это очень такая тяжелая тема в работе с клиентами.
И очень много раздумий.
Пожалуйста, если кого-то где-то накрыло, прикрыло, что-то прилетело,
подойдите к своему психотерапевту, скажите, у меня есть вот такая заборона,
я ее так чувствую, и пропрацуйте это все.
Я вас очень прошу. И осознание будет давать вам изменения.
Пожалуйста, бережите себя, это самое главное.
Я не знаю, кто там что сегодня взял для себя, хоть какой-то плюсик мне поставьте,
чтобы я поняла, что вы сегодня там что-то было нормальное, какую-то реакцию.
Я знаю, что вы на изнеможении, но какую-то реакцию, живая или здоровая, Настя, да, что там, скажи.
итог хотелось подвести.
Ведя итог, что
на сегодняшний момент
нет людей, которые могут мне что-то
заборонить. Есть только один человек,
это я.
Вот умничка, самостоятельная девочка.
Сразу вижу.
Самостоятельная девочка.
Сам стелюсь, а сам лягаю.
Да, так он и я.
Так и есть. Спасибо, Настля.
А еще, это прикольно.
Хочу быть сильной, я могу быть всем, кем угодно.
Хочу быть сильной, я хочу быть слабой.
развиваем то что было мало развито остальное принимаем и понимаем быть слабо тоже нормально
это про уязвимость да это важно ли ну очень интересная сегодня конечно лекция была такая
познавательная сравнительная да когда я себя сравнивала со всеми когда мифическими героями
Ну, сделал вывод, что все-таки меня сегодня ничего не триггернуло.
Так вот, чтобы именно триггернуло и накрыло.
Мой вывод тот, что все-таки я правильно живу.
Я правильно живу, и я позволяю себе быть.
Радости делать не тогда, когда там что-то я сделала, и пойти себя порадовать.
Я хочу, я радуюсь. Я не хочу, я не радуюсь.
Я хочу, я пошла, закрылась в комнатке и сижу себе, да, в тишине.
Ну, то есть, круто, конечно, все.
У меня даже история с моей коллегой закончилась очень-даже очень для меня, то есть, ух, вообще.
Так что, да, и я хотела поблагодарить Влад, потому что фраза ваша, когда вы сказали, вы бежите за ней и выпрашиваете у нее любовь, то есть она вот меня тогда триггернула, конечно, и у меня прям картинка все время стояла.
Ну, потом наступил момент, когда я увидела с ней другую картинку, и у меня вот так все поменялось.
Не бегаете, Лен, больше? Не догоняете никого?
Нет, я могу вкратце рассказать. Я прихожу на работу, это полсекундочки, захожу на работу, она сидит в конце дня, у нее подносик, фарфоровая чашечка на блюдечке стоит, рядом креманочки, варенье и рядом печенька.
И я захожу, и у меня сразу картинка, вот она, любовь к себе.
Ага, ну хорошо.
есть почему-то и потом у меня как пазлы пошло вот как карточный домик рассыпаться но это самое начало
у меня складываться что вот она сказала и пошла то есть я ее жизнь ее поведение одела на себя что
вы не надо вообще кому-то что-то доказывать сказала и пошла кому это интересно тебя довольно это очень
круто и после вот этих вот осознаний у меня расправились плечи у меня замедлилась походка
Я ничего для этого не делала специально
И сейчас на меня люди смотрят
Что первые дни я даже думала
Может я брюки забыла одеть
Может я там что-то не одела
Это очень круто
Вот именно тогда
Спасибо за тот толчок
Который вы дали одной фразой
Спасибо, что терпели мою историю
С коллегой
Мы теперь по креманке с вареньем
Лена достанем
Кто банку, кто креманку
и все будем жить свою долгую
и счастливую жизнь. И будем рассказывать
это любовь к себе. Вот так вот.
Ладно. Чудесно,
что у нас есть хэппи-энд.
Я вас всех поддерживаю.
Пожалуйста, берегите себя.
Анализируйте,
экспериментируйте. Прям буду рада
вас видеть в следующий раз. До новой встречи.
Все. Мои хорошие. Пока.
Отдых.